[Music]
welcome back to the
feed a world corporate chess
championship i'm grand master robert
house alongside me the one the only dina
belenka
dina how are you doing today i'm doing
great robert how are you uh you know
it's another
fun day this corporate chess event has
been a
really fun one because teams from all
around the world are taking part
they are representing their companies
they're playing alongside their
colleagues
and i think many are having a great time
so i'm happy to be here dina and i think
we'll have some great chess
as we'll find out who qualifies for the
playoffs tomorrow
absolutely and while we were talking
beforehand you are familiar with many of
these teams
uh you know there's a team from your
native town
right so your hometown uh city
so that's really cool um that's a great
thing in this
division that we're covering now so
let's remind everybody of what's
happening here what the format is
because we're in the pool stage and
after
the three rounds we're about to see then
we'll be determined who makes the
playoff each team
four players a minimum one male player
minimum
one female player and you can have some
reserves they're playing at a time
patrol of 10 minutes
with a two second increment so dina
that's pretty fast time control for
some people who may not be used to
playing online yeah that's a that's
actually a very nice time control it's
like um
a nice blitz like you have some minutes
to spend in the opening to make it
correctly not to mess up the the the
lines the theory
and then the blitz starts so it's it's
pretty comfortable it's way more
comfortable than title tuesday
for instance so yeah i personally
experienced this time control i was
playing european online
chess championship on chess.com and yeah
i can say that it's a very comfortable
one
it absolutely is and uh we have the
uh actually games are starting right now
so uh just
get right to that it looks like on time
which is lovely
huge event lots of things going on
behind the scenes but we do have yon de
palma she's game
on screen here and well that rating of
his opponent says 2166 but we know
pavel pavel is not a 2166 he's a very
strong
grandmaster this is just the rapid
online rating so clear that
well pavel doesn't play in this time
control just like many of the others so
dina
we off off to the start here we had a
french defense we'll just
show everybody how we got to this point
and this is all normal capturing on e4
knight to d7 that may block in your
bishop but let's be honest that french
bishop doesn't do much anyway
so the knight comes out to f6 the knight
can recapture
and what's your experience like in the
french do you know
well i can for sure say that this is
quite a rare line that you do usually in
order to avoid the theory and that's
what pavel does and pile by the way
is uh indeed my favorite because he
represents the pool cover team uh the
the pool cover airport st
petersburg as you mentioned in the
beginning so yeah even though
yanipon she is a pretty experienced
uh young gentleman i still root for
pavel
and pretty experience i i really like
the way you framed that because
uh we all know young palms he's in a tie
for first place in the candidates
tournament
that decides who goes on to face magnus
carlsen in the world championship
so jan he is so experienced that he can
move his knight
many times in the opening notice that
this knight went from
f3 that's one turn two turns 95
and once powell challenged the knight
third night move already in the opening
pavlok goes back he says i don't want
your knight on e5 that's bothering me
taking up space but this knight on c4 is
perfectly fine here
i think that yan's position it's it's
slightly better it's preferable
but isn't black super solid how are you
gonna crash through for yon
i guess you just need to increase your
your space advantage by advancing the
pawns the central pawns the
the a pawn and yeah it's it's something
like in the middle of
uh a little bit better for white and uh
and equal but you still you cannot call
it equal and you cannot call it a
advantage for white so yes it's it's
kind of evaluation that doesn't exist
yet
i i like the way you put that too
because it's true where we see these
knight on c4 a little bit more advanced
than blacks 9 and f6 the pawn on d4
clearly the best pawn on the board more
advanced than the pawn e6
and black's bishop on c8 is stuck at
home behind that pawn not doing so much
so
yeah white has a slightly preferable
position but it's hard to see
where exactly the advantage will come
from going forward so
jan off to a good start but pavel yeah
he's right at home let's uh
keep on going we have many games
underway i see the game between grand
masters sergey aronberg
and vladislav artemyev another
heavyweight matchup and you know this
position
i think is looks very nice for white
there's a bishop on b3
slicing across the board towards the
enemy king this
pawn structure with these pawns from c7
to e5 and f6 e5 show that black is
very very solid so i always get
frustrated you know what about you when
you see a position like this you know
that white
should be better but how do you break
through this no pawns have been traded
yeah that's not so easy but what can you
see is that the king the black king is
certainly
in danger here at least he doesn't feel
comfortable well it might still be solid
for black but there is certainly a way
how to break through
yeah that's right this knight came back
to f7 trying to continue the
solid position everything is towards
black center
and artemia he is one of the best
players in the world
sergey arenberg also a very strong
grandmaster representing paypal
bulgaria and when you're a little bit
rusty
like sergey might be because he's not a
full-time chess professional as
artemia is it can be difficult to
find ways to poke and prod through such
a position
where maybe you play d5 but that could
lock up the center of the board
and as soon as you play d5 black gets f5
right that's a typical break
that you have to look out for even
though d5 gains a tempo
gain space in the center it also
releases the tension so i think these
decisions are much more difficult to
make
and i'm sort of speaking a little bit
from experience you know when you're
don't play as much
chess anymore yeah you definitely do not
want to play d5 in this position for
white
right because because it releases the
tension but if you don't play d5
what do you do i guess so once again you
need to increase the the space advantage
go with a4
a5 preferably maybe bring the rook the
you usually when you don't know what to
do
in any position you just ask yourself a
very simple question okay what is my
worst piece and the worst piece here for
what is the rook on a1 so you just play
something like queen d2
d1 sounds sounds nice to me
it's just i always laugh because you
know queen each of you rookie
you just are asking the right questions
you're figuring out the right strategy
here
and even when i get that i'm like wait
what next because if i ever take on e5
all of black's pieces are aiming at that
square you can even take with the f pawn
so
i see these plans i completely agree
with you but what always gets me and we
have the eval bar off the sides like the
slightest bit better for white
i tend to feel like i should be even
have even more an advantage than
0.17 that it says here because the
knight on c4 is more advanced than
black's pieces
you know everything looks proper for
white whereas blacks has this f6 the
kingdom g7 that could be
considered as potentially vulnerable and
yet there's no advantage it's just
like usually it's really like step by
step you improve piece by piece so yeah
what concerns your
your your knight on c4 you definitely
want to reassure it's safe position like
by playing a4
and then you see you do it little by
little you have to have patience when
playing chess
yes that's true uh sometimes humans
we're not so great at being patient i
think we can all agree to that and we
just go for
in you know an h4 type of move because
we need to attack
but then after h4 wait my king that that
becomes weaker but h4 is
you know could be a plan at some moment
i just wouldn't rush that decision
against artemyev and speaking of not
rushing artemy has been sitting and
thinking for a while
so we'll leave him here trying to figure
out you know if he should bring his
queen out to e7 and connect his rooks
or if this knight will then reroute to
e3 and d5 that's another planet in
addition to dina's a4
a5 and queen d2 white seems to have more
to play for at this moment but artemia
you know he's very strong he can figure
this out so let's uh hop on over
in each gary playing he has the white
pieces against
feeding master vladimir antonenko and
well he has better control over the
center despite the worst looking pawn
structure right you know these double f
plots that people think double bonds are
bad
here they're really good because double
pawns open more files and the e files
under white's control
absolutely and you may even have one day
the plan of playing
breakthrough f5 if you block the e5
square so there is actually a lot of
potential you cannot even attack
by playing g4 g5 so yes absolutely this
double f4 pawn is definitely a force
not a weakness yeah it's something that
some newer players who may be watching
say double pawns no
those stack pawns not good but you just
have all the control
look at everything eyeing this e5 square
black can't use that and knight h5
hits the pawn and i think one of the
reasons black plays is is
g3 can defend the pawn very simply and
he has it quickly
but it closes off this queen you know
essentially like when a rook lift
happens and the rook gets over to
on the third rank the queen could also
do that and now the attack doesn't feel
as strong
or at least you don't see how white is
going to go and checkmate you so like
i guess antoningo says i have nothing
better to do i'll just move back and
forth and anisha says hey let's uh let's
trade those queens off
it's a very interesting decision yeah
definitely surprising one
i guess it's the space we keep talking
in various positions about the space
he would have taken back with the f on
instead he just trades queens
voluntarily so
there's a three on two advantage if we
cut the board at the c
file right white has an extra pawn on
the queen side i'm guessing anish
is going to try to create a pass pawn on
that side of the board and say my knight
blockades
your pawn on d5 my f4 pawn takes away
the e5 push
so white's pawns have a little bit more
mobility going forward
absolutely and you still want to bring
somehow the the a-rock to
to the game and unfortunately for the
moment at least you're tied down and if
that
could mean that anish puts a piece on b5
and
saves that pawn but he could also start
by bringing his king up
that g4 move not out of the question
there it is to gain some space
so we've seen so far games that are just
about gaining space
where one side has a clear plan and the
other side just
is not in bad shape but doesn't have the
same objectives um
so let's see we uh have
well magnus carlsen's game kind of hard
to
disagree with going to that game and
playing a player
much lower rated great opportunity uh
for
his opponent and he plays this line
where you have the
pawn triangle from b2 to d4 and back
over to f2
so dina what would your advice be to a
player who's
very outraged against the world champion
but has a solid start like what kind of
advice if you could just
say here let's have a timeout quickly
here's some psychological tips
what would you say well i would
definitely be happy at least comfortable
here with this position with black
because we can see we can see some kind
of
london uh with the bishop on g5 and
it is a solid it's a solid one so if i
were
at the place of the of the black here i
would definitely be happy with the
with the thing that uh i would i shall
not die soon
i shall last for some time versus magnus
carlsen because
he definitely will outplay his opponent
but uh this will take
time this will take more time when uh if
the position was pretty sharp
yes it's a position that black even
everything right so far
magnus is spending time we have him on
camera here he hasn't moved yet it's
about
even on the clock that's already an
accomplishment because
sometimes when you're outraged you see
that your
opponent just moving instantly and that
could be psychologically uncomfortable
but b6 i like that move getting ready
for an eventual c5
you can even play a5 we talked a lot
about gaining space
and if you play a5 maybe you go bishop
a6 because that bishop on
c8 doesn't exactly have the most
promising diagonal to work with so
sometimes you try to trade off this
bishop on d3 which is a very powerful
piece
that can attack the black king yeah
definitely developing the last
piece that hasn't been yet in the game
that's right so magnus is really you
know sitting and not moving
um i i wonder what he's considering at
this point
uh the knight to e5 that would be a very
committal decision so if he's trying to
think do i jump my knight to the center
sometimes you make a move like that and
you really regret it because the change
in pawn structure so if you played 95
and then we get this capture you can
already see that the eval bar so it's
the favor
black and that's because these double
pawns they can be attacked whether by
knight to d7
and the attack for white with like queen
h5 it's a bit
slow so the problems are not worth it
just for the
hope of getting that attack
yeah i think it's um what we can see
definitely here is that there is an
advantage for
psychological advantage for black that
at least the world champion is thinking
whoa and he played 95 so even though the
engine bar starts creaking in black's
favor a little bit slightly
that means that magnus took a deep think
he understood how committal this choice
is
and if it is not good and like sometimes
you make this move
all of a sudden you just lose the pawn
that gets on e5 that would be terrible
but magnus assesses that even if it may
be a position where black has some
chances now he likes his chances he is
the world champion he's playing
someone who is much lower than he is but
black
so far solid maybe can take advantage of
this and well plays bishop b7
i think that so far the players saying i
don't want to risk anything
i'm just playing a solid game i know
what my setup is like and maybe this
knight will
copy whites and jump into the e4 square
suit
why not definitely good question
why not hey i think that he agrees and
just
trying to deal with it but queen f3
magnus all right he's turning on the
jets i think that this queen
is about to head over to h3 and this can
be very scary we tend to trust magnus
when he's playing and that he's seeing
good ideas and if you are
at this rating disadvantage do you
really like wait do i trust him
but you should always be skeptical as a
chess player even if you're playing
magnus like
you know magnus is doing this so it's
probably pretty decent but let's
evaluate not let's not just trust it we
need to be
objective and not play the opponent we
should play the board
yeah the interesting part about it is
that you should you know for sure that
you are way more motivated for this
for this game that you're opening
because uh being at magnus place and
facing openings uh 800 points less it's
not
it's not that motivating for him so he
definitely has to to force himself to
play his best and
he has the pressure of the whole world
watching him
certainly does and uh we see uh in this
matchup between kindred and
bite dance and we want to bring
attention to a tweet we saw yesterday
which was really great to see and this
is how much this can mean to people
look at oracle tweeting about their
player santosh hassan
senpai who played against magnus carlsen
calling it a once in a lifetime
experience it certainly
was so a great thing to see where the
players
they just are so thrilled to have the
chance to play against mags i know
there's been some talk like
why are these top players participating
you know
shouldn't it just be people who work at
the company look at how happy
uh they are and it's just a great chance
for it's a once-in-a-lifetime experience
it really is how often does anybody get
to play magnus
not not very unless you're a top 20
player in the world
indeed it's an opportunity that you
can't miss
yes and well how crazy would it be if
magnus lost a game
to uh one of these players right you're
just like oh i'm playing in my corporate
you know you call your friend
calls you hey are you have any plans for
the weekend oh i'm just playing in you
know this corporate
world chess championship it's gonna be
fun hopefully play people around my
strength inactive players
and then the next thing you know you're
texting all your friends i'm playing the
world champion imagine if you can
at least draw the world champion in the
game that would be the most exciting
thing ever
you don't seem to be too optimistic
about that possibility sometimes it's
just a dream and then one day it comes
through
yeah that's that's true so we'll see
we'll
of course come back to this at some
point but right now black is
deep in the think tank trying to figure
out how vicious is this checkmating
attack
because it could be scary so let's keep
on going i'm just going to click
on you know many games open click on a
random game here
so let's go to this game oh okay mad joe
see we have this that's uh that's a
problem
those are rooks that are under that's
the right moment to click on this game
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
move on because it hurts to see when uh
rooks are
in this kind of situation and
unfortunately actually if we go back
a move here rook c2 was played which
walks into this idea so that's
unfortunate you try not to put your
pieces on the
same color as your opponent's bishop
especially in the opposite color bishop
position so
a one move blunder unfortunately that
loses some material so let's uh
let's go back to yon napomchi against
pavalo and nissimo because i just saw
that at the corner of my eye and
yan is doing what yan does best
attacking
attacking and h5 so
do you know a move like h5 i think it's
very difficult for many people to play
because they're told
not to push pawns in front of their king
and by the way 25 seconds for pavel
oh wow this is no fun
he's still holding somehow yeah you
definitely play h5 only if you've
calculated it all through
and i guess here in yeah there is a way
to there if queen h6 would not work so
there there was a way to save it
e5 right queen chase there's e5 so
playing g4 first trying to rip open the
position and maybe you sacrifice the
bishop
queen h6 pawn takes h5 and go for a
checkmate but jan's up
so much time that he should really
calculate that doesn't
backfire because some sometimes you
sacrifice a piece thinking you're gonna
go checkmate your opponent
and then it clearly doesn't work and
then you're just down a piece so if jan
is indeed going to play a move like
queen h6 which i think
works here he should calculate it for a
little bit because
queen h6 e5 you don't just want to give
away your bishop but you see look at
that
evaluation go all the way up there
clearly white is doing well
so queen h6 e5 and what's he gonna do
dina there he goes
yeah that was an easy one unfortunately
for pyle his position seemed to be
holdable
just before yes and although in the
practical
practical way it's uh yeah with this
time it's pretty
pretty quick death here yeah because the
king has nowhere to go queen h7
checkmate is the threat
if you take on g6 the queen takes uh
back and the king is forced in the
corner
and you're gonna see a checkmate where
this rook comes to g1 and the queen
delivers a mate either on g7
or on the h file there's actually no way
out of this but i i think jan is
demonstrating an important lesson for
everybody even if he is completely
winning he probably knows he's
completely winning
he's still spending his time because you
make some inaccurate move
your advantage could go away he knows
that he is about to win this game just
be ultra precise when you have an extra
three plus minutes in the clock there
might actually have been a new trade
that he has learned recently from
making so many mistakes when when
playing the moves too fast because
jan is actually known to be uh to be
a bullet style player and making a lot
of mistakes when playing too fast
that's right he has any classical
tournaments as well so
this is a good thing that he's slowed
down he's playing on a team you know
this not just about his game but
he does deliver a victory for the team
because queen g7 is checkmate and
otherwise queen
h6 you can't stop both and you can
barely stop one
so that's uh just how the game would
have ended if not on time so let's keep
on going here
we have so many games let's see anish
geary
were at his game earlier okay now the
end game is
up a pawn for white and his pieces are
just dominating the board this knight on
d4 hasn't left
it's just such a good night in the
blockading square yeah that's a perfect
night when playing versus an isolated
poem
and black pieces seems to be extremely
passive so yeah a very clear advantage
for white
and f6 check if you take with the rook
there's rook h7 the bishop is
open now yeah that's there it goes and
the king
you know why anish won this this game he
brought his king up he used as a weapon
in the end game the king is not going to
be attacked so you can use it to your
advantage and that's what in each day he
wins the game
and i know that there's other very
strong players on the optivar team
we see that with the white pieces here
at david pardo simon
he has up one pawn and
looks like has a great position with
this one once again an isolated pawn
which is not what
located yet so yeah if there was a
chance to bring this knight from
h5 to d4 that would be just amazing
it i don't know how i'm trying to figure
out like i guess you gotta go g4 and
then
bring that knight around takes a little
bit of time but i guess then on h5 is
really annoying for
black to deal with because you can't
double rooks you can even once uh
prepare
the f4 past pawn and then the knight
would become a real force
and it's interesting is that it's the
advantage is there for white we see the
evaluation bar and we don't have the
moves so it seems like a lot of moves
will be good for white
but sometimes you make just this
careless move and your whole advantage
goes away
so i think that you do need to still be
a bit precise but i think you and i
agree
white's position is super good here it
just should be yeah
i actually think that there is a lot of
uh potential here like on the practical
level
there is not such a chance to make a a
big mistake here okay
you can be not exactly precise but
no chance for making mistakes here to my
concern
yes i i agree so f4 played your idea
great if you take on h5 rook takes now
hitting this h6 pawn you're also hitting
the pawn on d5 if this g
pawn takes on f4 so it looks like white
is about to pick up another pawn black
also has no time
it's not a great situation to be in
when you're trying to defend against
such a strong player an international
master so
yeah i think that optivar is going to be
happy they're going to
take two games to start in this match
and
they're going to try to keep pushing
towards the top i'm going to just try to
look around here
to see this is optiver's board 4 and
unfortunately with the black pieces it
looks like
she's in trouble because the rook landed
on a7 that means this pawn on c7
is going down and black's also down a
lot of material
so optima is going to lose on the sport
unfortunately for them
yes and i'm just gonna just keep going
clicking on games that catch my eye
i want here we have what is at least by
the
evaluation bar a pretty even position
but i look at this and i think that
both sides have chances
what do you think dino when you look at
this yeah this is a pretty double dashed
end game because uh from white side
white has a past pawn
on a file which is pretty good for the
end game because it's a um
it's the past phone of the border but um
at the same time yeah the king is in
danger even though it's an end game the
king on h3 could be in danger
and uh the rook oh the rook on d2 is
extremely active so
what needs to be extremely careful here
i agree especially in
with under a minute left for both sides
there is actually a mate hanging there
something like bishop f1 and rook h2o so
that like
let's say something like knight f a
trying to exchange pieces would not work
because of the
immediate mate surprise good fine dina's
been doing her tactics that's a
checkmate
right there so you have to be very
careful because knight f8 would be a
fun move to play and whoa bishop d3
knight to b6
you see black's advantages going up but
the players don't know that they
can sense okay i like my chances but
neither player knows that black is
well bordering on winning at this point
yeah i guess the knight needs to come to
d4 and then to f3 and it will be
extremely
dangerous but knight d4 here this bishop
takes f5 a cool tactic amazing
because this is there's a pin here in 13
seconds he's like d5
oh he sees that i like that move good
pawns here
and well this bishop has to go back and
i'm even looking at knight g5 check
at some moment it's kind of similar
checkmate plan
oh oh dropping that pawn and then the
knight
knight takes f4 still hanging oh neither
player sees it though that's still a
good move by black
just taking advantage of the pin like if
a black there is still advantage
yeah because sometimes you missed your
opportunity to take a pawn on that four
which wins a piece
and then you don't have a second chance
but he actually is just it's actually a
third chance already
i lost count i lost count and uh you can
take that no way king will protect it
there we go there we go finally taking
something
two past bones yeah finally he takes all
now perfect moment yeah this is uh
clearly a win for black here and in time
trouble
you know being super accurate very
difficult
but black had a nice looking position an
aggressive one
and ended up winning the game even
though we tune in it's the eval box it's
slight advantage for white so
we've seen lots of good things happen so
far i'm just gonna
click on i guess when as long as you
have an advantage even if you don't find
the best moves but you still keep the
advantage it's all fine
yes that's what black did even if they
didn't take the f4 pawn
that's right and this is another game in
the october match
it looks like uh observer's gonna win
because javier with the
black pieces is up two pawns
and also up just the world on the clock
and
so much extra time here
so it's going to be a three one finish
it looks like for optivar
and i'm trying to look what other games
are still going there are plenty left
so i'm just gonna see here let's click
on this game
it's maria music okay we have a game
here
where opposite color bishops dina but
black is up a pawn
yet it feels at first glance like
white's king is safer
tucked in the corner and this bishop on
d5 but i like that move rookie three
because they're starting to feel unsafe
trading a pair of rooks seems like a
good decision but i guess it's all about
the pieces
and here we clearly see that yeah
well the rook the black rook coming to
a2 might be a lot of danger
well the bishop on d5 seems extremely
stronger than the bishop on f6 so i
definitely do not understand as well as
you from the first glance why
black is being better here but i guess
there's the reason might
might be the pawn on d4 yeah
could be dangerous and if we count the
number of phones we're pulling up
right but it's funny because you know we
we both acknowledge extra pawn pawn d4
is maybe that extra problem looks good
but minus two
i don't think that maria thinks that way
right that's the difference when you're
playing and you
versus seeing the evaluation because
she's like i should be doing well that
would be my
mindset black it looks like you're doing
well you have a pawn
but you don't see a clear path forward
and you see that white's rooks
are teamed up here at least causing you
some problems but i like this rook on
a6 the queen on e7 really nice move
maybe trade off
one set of the rooks and that could help
ease black spheres the concerns about
her king on g7 absolutely
so i think that this is a position where
she can play pretty freely she's doing
well on the clock two minutes and 40
seconds with that extra pawn
and this is a grand master battle in uh
you know in this pool here so that's
that
that exact case when when the position
the evaluation from the engine doesn't
correspond to the
practical situation on the board you
don't feel this minus two when you're
playing white here
no yeah it's true you think okay how can
i get chances that's how you're thinking
not in terms
of the evaluation and look queen c8
already direct threat where does that
work go it can be a bit nervous
because do i might work on b6 do i put
my work on d6 i need to keep my rook
here
oh my oh no brook
you know this is a perfect strategy when
you're playing blitz you just
continue attacking all over there and uh
sooner or later your opponent
won't see yeah oh gosh because she was
playing
such good defense there and she went for
the offense all of a sudden and then the
rook is just
hanging and there's no follow-up
okay is d3 it's still not over i mean
yes
well actually queen takes f6
uh is a possibility here because the
rook does defend there
so queen takes queen takes and then d2
ah so you can just go and get it it's
funny it takes on d2
yeah it looks like oh wait a second i
can you cannot play bishop f1 okay you
can
bishop f3 will take and rook takes f3
see that's how games turn around real
quick good eye
so uh you can't take that bishop uh on
f6 which now makes it look a little bit
uncomfortable for white even though
you're upper rook you need to be very
careful
because that pawn is running yeah they
have two minutes to
come up with a move queen a2 that's good
move
seems to be a very practical decision
yeah
and it's it's funny you know if white
did not have the time
you know did not have two minutes plus i
think you could see queen takes f6
because
it's not clear what's immediately wrong
with it and when you take on f6 you're
hitting the f7 pawn but this d-pawn is
so strong that's
black's only form of compensation so
making sure that pawn can't push
is the first step and if you take on f7
this queen
can take back so be careful about
decisions like this
because if you take the queen oh when
you're queen yeah well then you lose
this bishop rather and then the bishop
and then this d-pad
is the strongest uh pawn and doing very
well so you would have to
take him totally losing for for white
even though they are
they were queen up yes so you'd have to
actually take the rook on e1
because if the bishop takes then you
take the queen but this is fancy tactics
we'll see
if it's played because rook f7 is
actually a very good move to trade off
pieces
and take this plate take this rook after
so
so far it's been a nice game from
white's perspective since we tuned in it
started off
great position for maria she
unfortunately hung her rook on a6
and now white is making sure that he can
get a
winning advantage without the same risk
yeah this looks pretty pretty over to be
honest
yeah it's kind of an accident still
unfortunately marie is a professional
she finds until the end but when the
game is over she might
regret it a lot yeah it's
such a good oh oh oh no so queen f2
here comes queen e1 ideas
look at this the game's never over till
it's over i honestly was like
thinking oh it looks really bad she must
be real upset but this is so difficult
to win when the opponents have passed
pawn like this
and what was the mistake there we go we
just uh we were almost uh
about to to switch to the next game yeah
and
what was in the mistake of this position
d2 played it's
plus seven and rookie ones the most
obvious move right of course rook to d1
and yet rook d1 blocking the pawn the
advantage goes away because of queen f2
chess is just a wild game so
queen one i know how okay queenie one
amazing because the bishop is protecting
yeah i was thinking of something like
bishop e5 trading the maid but
i guess that would be bishop g2 yeah
yeah oh wow that's actually how you
could even win game it's a good call
you know where you just say i'm not
going to focus on the
my password i'm going to go for
checkmate but this bishop is the bishop
g2
and they say when there's wait yeah it's
it's
there is still something here okay nice
you're going right for the checkmate i'm
gonna follow your lead because h3 in
comes the queen
g3 yes incredible this is getting scary
for white all of a sudden
i'm not sure if there's a mate here
there might be a perpetual
right you can just try sure but at least
you have a draw with black which is
already an achievement
in such a position wow and
okay she's thinking she can't play
queenie one check but bishop e5
now looks clearer because you know what
yeah sorry
i'm pretty sure that even when she she
sees this this line
uh she can possibly tell herself oh this
is a draw and i don't want to draw i
won't win in this game
yeah and maybe she does i i don't know
her team situation off
uh top of my head i haven't seen the
results maybe we could find it out but
if maybe she needs to uh
play for more that could be possible but
if that if a draw was needed by white
he could just take that queen there and
trade everything off so why can can't
lose the game
if you take the queen when it lands back
on e1 but
okay you have to be super careful about
that bishop e5 idea
absolutely
yeah it still seems quite secure for for
black so
in the worst case we still have a
perpetual but we can't even
try to see something more and i guess in
such wait you can't go bishop g2 because
queen in tribes mate
oh my gosh dino
rook h1 okay is it the only move
and then queen rook d2 oh well we
already
cut back the okay so queen d3 wins the
b3 pawn and then
all of a sudden black has another pass
pawn
amazing amazing queen of five
king h4 queen of trump checkmate in two
championships but she has 10 seconds
left this game has been
absolutely wild okay there's no more
mate
this is a check and the check that would
win the bishop so if the queen comes to
defend that's a good move
i think this is about to be a draw both
players are probably nervous as heck
oh no
oh chess is such a wonderful game and
when you're playing just
bullet chess checkmating two she missed
that and you know what it's
it's two seconds increment it's it's
pretty
a lot to be honest especially for those
players they are experienced to play
three plus zero three plus one but
let's do is a lot it is
a lot but if you're not used to playing
online you just start feeling nervous
when you see
the clock ticking out down that way and
you see the milliseconds
so it's like okay i i gotta move
i can't freeze and so you just make one
i think you know if we go back
to uh this position here
once the king went to h3 it looks like
white was playing for win
but sometimes you play for a win and
you're really playing for a loss because
you're getting your king in big trouble
so rook takes d2 queen g1 queen d3 was
good
and king g4 i don't think that uh white
ever turned off
the like the winning switch first white
was worse
we came in there's like minus two black
was doing really well up a pawn
then white was winning because maria
hung her rook on a6
and then was it okay i'm going to win
this game i'm going to win this game and
then you make me like king g4
which under other circumstances you
would never make this move why is your
king going out to g4 you're walking into
danger
kng2 is much safer of course
yeah just i mean here we go yeah that
was a total um
total mess here with the checkmate in
two i guess you will see
it in her nightmares yeah hopefully
uh nobody tells her about this until
after today's rounds are done you know
if you play one game a day you can be
told afterwards and then you have a
whole day to recover
the next round starts in not too long
from now so
you're gonna want to forget about this
this game was a nightmare this
blundering the rook on a6
then white playing rook to d1 a lot of
missed opportunities for the players
and this one it's a mate and two so you
think how could a player as strong as
maria moosie should
miss this the answer likely comes down
to the fact she's not that much time
and she was down a rook just a few moves
ago so she wasn't playing
for a win it's really hard to make that
a flip in your mind of oh i'm just
trying to hold
the uh and try to survive somehow to
wait now i can just go win so
i get it she want queen d3 to take b3
and essentially pre-move that mentally
dude would you say that's kind of a fair
assessment or should she still have
found the mate i think
i think she should have still found it
i'm pretty sure like knowing uh maria
how
ambitious she is i'm pretty sure even if
when she
even when she blundered the the rook the
moment that her pawn got to d2
she she knew she she had chances to
fight for win
so i'm absolutely sure once she sees it
she will be very very
frustrated yeah and she is she's a world
ex champion after all
right it's uh 14 seconds left
crazy things happen in time trouble
so it's understandable we've seen
all the top players in the world make
mistakes and with no time on the clock
but yeah queen f5
uh just i think a lot of this came
unexpectedly to her
she probably to some extent was almost
gonna resign like
once you dropped her rook and she did
fight hard but
yeah you have to play queen of five
check obviously now that i think about
it don't you think that it might have
been a pre-move queen takes b3 because
she didn't expect king g4
we actually saw it quite fast queen b3
she played uh let's go back here let me
see she played queen takes b3 in five
seconds so she actually spent time
okay yeah she needs ben time yeah yeah
so i i just there's a lot
going through the player's heads i lost
swirling like oh is queen h7 check is
that going to
be a problem for me or what's the deal
but yeah it's
it's a shame but we don't want to harp
on too much because i know i've missed
plenty of checkmated ones even
when the time starts getting low so
no questions for me about it it just
happens
and i'm just trying to see if we have
more games it looks like the games are
done
uh for now so well dean it's been a fun
round i
i can't believe we ended on that note
where we saw two gray masters slugging
it out and
missed checkmates hanging brooks but
that's the nature of
a rapid chest for you right he gets the
blitz chest he gets the bullet chest
and crazy things happen yeah that's the
the nature of chess playing online
especially but it happens in person too
right when you're playing
speed chess pieces actually go flying
off the board right
someone makes a quick move and slams the
piece down and then the rook ends up
and over you know three aisles away so
uh
less that's peace banging but still lots
of craziness
yeah and at least playing online is not
as dangerous as uh playing real blitz
over the board because in this case as
you say pieces fly everywhere sometimes
they
they land into your eyes and uh might be
might be dangerous yeah this is the
pleasure of playing online
sounds like you're speaking from
experience a little bit do you have a
horror story about playing blitz and
some pieces flying at you
i think it's more about bullets
especially when you yeah
you you take some pieces and you cannot
even capture them with your hands so you
just
flew them away from the they flew away
from from the chessboard and then you
try to yeah
what you usually do you just press the
clock and you let your opponents uh
put all the pieces back into order on
the chess game where
on the board where like it's his time
which is uh pretty uh
forbidden in the rules exactly and
well considering there's a world
championship title the world corporate
championship
this is uh a lot of stake here so it's
good that the players
they're working hard they're trying
their best they get a break
so dina we're also going to take a break
and we will return in a bit
uh would you get a break now but the
next round begins i'm going to ask i
don't want to leave people hanging
just to make sure what time the next
round is
i should have in 50 minutes
okay can't do math it is in 50 minutes
it's 11 30 a.m
eastern time uh dina what time is that
in europe
it's uh it's almost 4 40. so it's a nice
moment to take a short break
and then get back with even more
exciting blunders
and a lot of energy absolutely we'll see
you soon everybody
[Music]
do
welcome back everybody to the feed a
world corporate chess championship
dino we had a very exciting round four
two rounds to go to determine which
teams will win their respective pools
and we've seen some leaders take their
aim at the title and other teams trying
to catch up so
what what do you think we're going to
see in the final two rounds nerves are
we going to see
teams with the strong players they going
to find their form and win
how do you see this event playing out
yeah absolutely i think that
uh the last couple of rounds is going to
be the most stressful ones
and we shall see a lot of blunders a lot
of nerves
unfortunately when you play chess you
need to be cold blood and if you don't
if you think about the result it can
become pretty messy
that's definitely true and you know this
is a tournament with
people representing their companies and
sometimes that means that there's an im
just hanging out with the company every
single day doing their job then
it is an event like this that comes
along you're like yes we gotta
show off our might and then sometimes
you have these people who don't play in
too many over-the-board tournaments so
their rating may not be stabilized
they may say 1700 but really they've
been studying they're practicing and
they put like a 2 000
plus player so it's very tricky and as
time goes on some of that rust it wears
off
and maybe the players who have been
playing for a long time their experience
will
show they will definitely fight
with the best they can and even though
it's a kind of a friendly tournament
it's still a competition and those of
them who are not professional chess
players right now they certainly were
before so they know what it is a game of
chess
whatever it is and wherever you play you
still play
you do your best and you you fight until
the end
definitely and we have a couple games to
show uh there was this critical moment
in the game between dimitri yaakovenko
who needs little introduction to the
world of chess
formerly up at like 2750 has rating has
decreased a bit but still an exceptional
player
in this position against uh jan sedoma
here
it's a grand master with black
international master white the position
is complicated right where
black has this past pawn in the making
on the queen side
but white has an extra pawn on the king
side so
the move that was played here you know
was queen to b6
and i think we can understand that after
queen c7 a
fatal error was made with knight to c4
allowing the queen trade and the knight
hopping away from the action
how do you uh you know how do you think
about a position like this so that
when you know our viewers are playing
they don't make a similar mistake
yeah well you look at this position you
definitely do not want to trade the
queens because
it's an end game and black has a pair of
bishops a
postponed past phone that is ready to
queen
it's uh it looks pretty dangerous and uh
the only thing that you are trying to
find here
is how to to trick your opponent to make
some checks some attacks with a queen
but definitely do not trade those
yeah i completely agree and queen f2
back is a good move
a pinning this pawn yeah black can play
f4 the game is still really complex it's
anybody's game honestly but you can see
it says zeros
and as soon as knight c4 is played it
plummets because black is winning all of
a sudden
and dimitri didn't need you know to ask
himself any questions he said let's just
trade queens
here comes b3 and after the knight takes
well
you can't even stop that pawn and if you
took on b3 i think he pro
maybe uh white overlooked that a3
is the way to go yeah he absolutely must
have missed this
uh this pawn breakthrough and
miscalculate
this whole situation otherwise he would
never make such a choice
yeah and definitely time travel played a
part because it's very
likely in your head you think okay b3
take take oh that's not that big a deal
and black is still for choice but as you
can see it's not
nearly as strong because this pawn can
be stopped bishop can come to d3
this knight can maybe come to c4 a4
depending on what black does
and that pawn is not queening just yet
but that's a typical pawn break right
you play b3
and after pawn takes we have to remind
ourselves we don't have to recapture
just because oftentimes we will make a
trade and recapture
here a3 is stronger because outside past
pawns are
very difficult and in this case
impossible to contain yeah as they say
we do not play drugs here we play chess
and captures are not uh
obliged exactly and that's a very
good comparison one that i was thinking
about but that's true you do not have to
recapture
and that's a typical way to spring free
a pass pawn
a three pawn would promote so
dimitriakovenko gets another victory
and we had another game that i had my
eye on when we were in break
because this is a position where
carolina ulcerova
representing csob the czech bank the
position for black is really good at
this point
but it's not losing for white nothing of
the sort but it's kind of hard to
find a move so i guess dina when i was
looking at this during our break i was
just
thinking how can we advise people when
they have a position like this
not a single piece has been traded how
do you go about thinking about a
position
and trying to come up with a plan it's
all about maneuvering and plans and the
person who has the right plan who fills
the position
can overplay the other one no matter
what is the the rating
it's all about the experience and
understanding about the the structure
the pawn structure here what we see
it's kind of a king's indian i would say
for white yep
so definitely yeah and we can see that
the center
is uh is still kind of
undecisive undecided so we can we can
see
either captures or d4 so as long as
the center is not closed we cannot
afford ourselves to play f4
so it makes a lot of um a lot of
pressure here for white
in order to understand what to do next
no that's a great way of putting it that
black has the better pawn center because
two pawns up on the
fifth rank white just has one pawn on
the fourth rank in the center and it's
hard to come up with a plan for white
the knight on h4 are you gonna bring it
to f5 can't just be captured
and really there is one two three
four attackers on this e4 pawn so
there's a lot of pressure
in the center and that's actually what
decided the game is right here white
with queen f3
which is a move that does make sense you
want to bring your knight to f5 and keep
that protected
but after pawn takes e4 we saw a series
of trades
and now bishop takes e4 was played
because
the bishop was defending when the queen
was back on e2
now that's the basic overcharge
and too many pieces are hanging where
you get
uh the rook here and instead of queen
takes e4 you think oh
i get two minor pieces for a rook and a
pawn that's the typical
trade that's good for the minor pieces
this king at the end of this line you
know six moves down the road
that's the problem is there's a back
rank issue more than anything so that
queen on f3
was tied in two directions to the e4
score and the d1 square stopping the
mate
overloaded queen that's a typical tactic
yeah that was a painful one i guess for
whites
we all uh make these kind of mistakes
especially in quicker time controls
where you know
if we just go back when not a single
piece had been traded at this point you
think well back rank problems what do
you mean
i guess the word here for white was uh
also because like you see okay how many
attackers you've calculated there are
five attackers how many defenders there
are
five defenders like there is a pawn
knight queen uh rook and the bishop but
you can see that there is the queen on
a6 that is actually willing to trade
with the queen a2 and that would
eliminate one defender
and then here we go the the rook on d1
on d8
threatening to take the rook on d1 so it
makes uh yeah it makes like
three defenders in the end of the day so
there was definitely a lot of pressure
on this e4 pawn
tactical pressure and the white couldn't
uh
make it work that's a good point that
actually there was a direct tactical
threat on the e4 square
which might mean that white needed to do
something very direct perhaps it was
a knight f5 type of move or even the
ugly f3
oh it hurts to see that move but it
moved like that yeah maybe it keeps the
material
but as you said the ugly move it
that looks difficult to play but white's
position is that difficult
it is even material not a single piece
has been traded
and yet the uh engine as we see it
really likes black because of the
activity
and the direct tactical threat on the e4
square so positions like this
you have to be extra careful and i think
that you know
carolina the higher rate of player she
got a very nice position in the opening
and she was able to convert
with ease so two fun games there one was
an endgame one was just a complex uh
just clogged position out of the opening
but either way
the chest is good and while we are in
focus on the chest so you know let's go
to the standings just to
see who's leading which companies will
be trying to win their pools here a
spare
in in group a and european investment
bank those are the
two teams at the top there with all
eight at a possible eight match points
but look at spare with 14 and a half
game points that's the first
thing we look at because that's how you
win your group is it already too late
for the other teams xena
okay let's count how many points do we
get for a win
uh so the first action it's board points
is the first
thing we look at so 14 and a half right
their board points is
that that's you can lose a match and
still win even if somebody else wins all
their matches
so one round is not enough but here we
go we have still two more rounds
so there might be a chance to to guess
bear
i guess the the despair team is pretty
pretty strong with uh yandy pognish on
the first board
bear is this spare bank but we shall not
come
uh confuses with the spare bond trade
union
right and then the team as you said john
napoli board one they have
a very strong feeding master kadatsuki
on board two they have international
master
on board three and even their board for
a 2250
women's international master that i mean
that team they're not going to lose too
many games
absolutely not so it looks like spare
doing really well although
in that pool you see european investment
bank they're going to try to beat them
head to head
tough match up in the group b gronkit
bank
yondex now that is a clash of titans
yeah the ranking bank is well known for
for being a sponsor of the grand ca
open annual open but as well as the the
bottom button one of the strongest
teams in in german buddhist league
for both men and women
so that's that's a big name like yandex
is a big company but it's not that known
in chess
at least it wasn't before maybe now that
we're the first
chess world corporate championships we
shall see a lot of new games
in a lot a lot of new teams soon in the
world
in the european club cops and so
maybe future stars
definitely yeah but for now yandex is
certainly not as known as as gran kabank
no but right now they have dimitri
yacovenko leading the charge and there
is an exact tie right they both have 13
board points throughout uh the four
rounds they have
all eight match points they've won their
matches so they're completely tied and
they're about to play one another so on
board one
we will see georg meyer taking on
um dimitri yakovenko so that will be a
lot of fun
and we will see you know who if
other teams like the airstrike group
there will have a chance but i think
between gronkie and yondex one of those
two
is going to come out on top and in this
c group you have morgan stanley hungary
very strong team filled with
international masters and strong players
from top to bottom
and you have uh rossetti volga
trying to catch up along with optivar
that's the anish giri team
if they can start winning all their
games they have a chance to catch up
they're only one and a half points
behind morgan stanley with eight games
to go
yeah i guess the weekends off up to our
team is their
board number four where the player one
thousand uh
rating right but he has still got one
point
out of four so it's uh it's a good
achievement so far
yeah she's a pretty new player i've
talked to anish and anish was telling me
that
uh you know they have their anisha is
playing on board once and each gear
needs
no introduction but then on they have an
international master
and another 2300 plus player so they
have very strong
title players in the top three boards
and their fourth board is somebody who's
newer to chess
but they had a training session optivar
loves chess they attend
the vik tournament every single year
with the exception of this year because
the pandemic
but they're dedicated to chess anisha's
had a relationship with the company for
many years now
so they're a big fan of the game and
they work hard so we'll see if they can
catch up and in group d we see that
if we uh show the next pools here
we have spare bank trade union you said
not to mistake spare and
uh the trade union oh these uh these
we'll update these
uh to get them after the next round
absolutely there's
yeah it needs to make a difference
between spare bank and spare but spare
is actually spare bank yeah it's the
the new world was inspired new um
abbreviation for bear bank right and
there it is look at our producers so
helpful there so spare
uh the trade union they actually are not
in first place but they're just a half
point behind and looks like dussault's
systems there
is in first place with 14 board points
doing really well
although slav group has ilya smirn
that's a team in third place
grand master ilya smirn from israel is
leading
their team so very good chances and then
i see in fourth place rosewood
technologies they're
in south africa if i'm not mistaken and
they also have a strong team
they have a chance but it looks like at
the top there the teams are
you know one of those top two teams are
the best chances because they'll likely
play each other
and the winner of that match will likely
come out of group d
group e we were just talking about the
czech bank
we saw carolina osarova's game she's on
board four and she's
a very strong player so i i mean it's
only a
half a point lead there too though so
group e is
wide open
so kaspersky as well i mean that's
kaspersky they've sponsored the
uh the world championships world
championship right in 2016.
yeah indeed between magus carlson and
sergey karakin
right yeah sorry go ahead dina yeah
in the united states right in new york
in my
home city i was there every single round
and they're
advertising you know their branding was
all over the place but it's great to see
that they were
sponsoring chess and of course tata you
know when you hear
see the company tata there you think
tata steel vikings a
and there's also the todd steel event
that was in india as part of the grand
chess tour one of the
events so a lot of companies that really
do give a lot to chess and in
group f have not looked too deeply
at their games but the state bank of
mongolia up at the top
filled with many of the best players
from the country it's good to see
mongolia putting together a team because
dean as we know
they have so many strong players
absolutely we can see
three title players here in their in
their team
and uh as you said uh one of the best
players of the country that that seems
to be a very
very solid team and they've taken an
interesting approach actually they've
put a
1400 player on board two and
international master
uh but uh on board three so they kind of
stacked their boards in a way
where their some of their lower rated
players are on higher boards than title
players
and that's an interesting strategy that
we see at olympiads i know the
azerbaijan team in particular they put
mama jarv on lower boards that
he could win a bunch of games whereas
maybe someone who's slightly lower rated
will hold
on a higher board so it's an interesting
strategy overall when teams do that
indeed yeah it's kind of uh testing
other ways to get through
all this concurrence exactly
and while we've been talking about the
standings about the companies about the
chess
we want to remind everybody it's call to
action just bring your attention to the
ongoing charity event fiji has been
involved with three projects
chess and education chess for people
with disabilities and the feed hs
veteran support program if you're able
to please consider a donation
using the command donate in chat or by
clicking the panel below the stream
and please if you can't do get involved
this is for
charity this is why the teams are
playing and there is a world
championship title at stake but it's
trying to
help these initiatives and do right so
thank you so much for all you who are
able to
and have been donating so dina i believe
for now there's about 10 minutes until
the round begins
we're going to take a quick break and
when we return we will be back
with round five of the pool stage
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
and we are back ready for round five
feed a world corporate chess
championship
dina we have some great matchups in
store we're about to find out which
teams are going to head into the final
round of the group stage
with the lead we can bring up those
pairings and talk about them
as the matchup is about to get on their
way see this top
left group a b to the next c and so on
look at some of these players here at
dino we have yon napamishi
taking part dimitri yakovenko against
georg meyer
in yandex vs granca we have
international master bragazzi taking on
grand master elusion
there on the group c korrabov against
twanberg
these are names that are just like the
who's who of chess really strong players
all around
but every board is equally important so
i want to stress that that
every single board has equal weight to
the match situation
and it could come down to board fours
not just board ones
absolutely we will witness the two the
two the last two decisive
rounds and uh this is the last moment to
trying to stop the leaders that's gonna
be pretty exciting
yes indeed and we like we keep saying we
will have some
great matchups georg meyer against
dimitriakovanko that could take place
in the gronkie chess classic we
mentioned how great they support chess
bon bon club and the uh gronkey
tournament so
we have liftoff it seems to see some
games starting here
and the first game that comes up is
grand master illusion
against international master brigadzi
and
i can read cyrillic dina so i gotta go
well
yeah i'm genuinely impressed yeah
i i got it so i was hoping to you for
you to need some help but
here we go you did it on your own uh
well every now and then
my uh russian abilities can come through
this is a very important moment so for
some of our newer viewers
it oh castle i love it upon sacrifice
but
pawn takes d4 knight 64 is a typical
blunder
thinking that's a free pawn because hey
my queen lands here it's not under
attack
when pieces are in line with one another
bishop b5 check get that piece out of
the way with force
you win the queen on d4 so that poem was
not actually hanging
but other plans were made by bragadzi he
actually says here have my pun look at
what is this dino explain this to me he
keeps
giving upon is he just what is this
opening
this is a typical french defense and a
very nice
pawn sacrifice yes you definitely want
to confuse your opponent
uh perhaps it's a it's a it's a
preparation
and some real line you want to yeah you
want to see
you want to get the the other one from
the book out of the book
it seems that it's justified based on
the
evaluation grammar solution says i don't
want that
and sometimes these traditional
grandmasters they say i'm not just going
to take your pieces that gives you two
quick play
and just a half move back here the
evaluation was
pretty level so if you take this pawn
pawn takes c3
you get the open b file maybe you'll
play pawn c4 to keep
opening the position and if you look at
who is the better development it's
obviously
white who is castled and has three minor
pieces out and this rook quickly comes
to b1 that will bring another piece into
the game so
a grand master elusion says i'm playing
h6 knight to b3 like come on
take on c3 finally at long last the pawn
was captured on c3
but dino we could see like just
continued quick play by white this
bishop to come out to e3 with tempo
what do you make of this is it
definitely a line that white uh
knows quite well and we can see that the
the
the pawn sacrifice is very much
justified you can see the
very big advantage in the development
you can see the white king already
castled the rook that comes on b1
so the queen on b6 will be absolutely
ridiculous it makes a lot of sense to me
this knight on e7 you don't really know
where it goes it cannot
go neither to f5 nor to g6 because you
will take it with the bishop
and yes how would you develop the f8
bishop perhaps you would have to go
something like g6 or g5
trying to attack on the on the king side
but at the same time where would you put
your key in
your black hair you wouldn't go to the
long castle because of the open b
file it's it's quite complex and um we
don't really see the easy plan of
development for black here
oh it looks pretty scary i like this
pawn sacrifice it's the milner berry
gambit
and i hear this in simon williams voice
because i've actually watched his
lesson videos on chess.com where he
talks about the french and
those videos are very high quality but
now that i
am seeing the name i'm not good with
names of openings and this pawn
sacrifice
it is known to the players in particular
to bergazzi he's now up
half a minute and he is down a pawn but
with the initiative and that's his style
he is
definitely a player who likes to be on
the attack and knight of five was played
big decision time
do i take on f5 after which he takes a
five hurts the pawn structure for black
but this bishop can maybe park itself on
e6 the dark square bishop can finally
develop and castle kingside feels safer
when this pawn is on f5 your king's not
under attack so much
i would still root for white here
because he would put your knight to d4
trying to attack the f5 pawn and even
the king
it would look safer there for black king
but still
for me the ninja would be definitely on
the right side
yes it's just a big decision right to
give up your bishop that
could be very powerful maybe you'll see
him with a g4 played
kicking that knight right back to e7
that's not out of the question
to say just go back your bishop's not
getting out but at any time you play g4
your king can become weaker so let's
keep on going
within these games here we have ray
suke nanjo international master from
japan
uh this is the matchup between morgan
stanley hungary and rosetti
volga look at this position i just saw
at the corner i saw pawn f4
dina this looks kind of scary for white
at first glance but then i noticed
wait this d5 pawn is pinned so can you
get away with taking this e4
pawn what do you make of this wild
position let us see if the e3 pawn
is not uh under attack as well like if
there's
knight a 94 followed by f takes e3 f
takes c3
okay you take with this knight makes
sense well
um i guess it's all about the king's
safety
yeah i think the king here is much safer
even though king h8 to force that knight
to move and
i don't know it's one of these
situations where you can be greedy and
take this pawn e4
but perhaps you're better off not doing
so i just like the look of black's
position you're
all out aggressive and where is white's
king going to go
it's probably going to have to go to the
queen side but you push these pawns up
in a4 and
b4 so if black gets a b6 type of move
perhaps that will open that side as well
but
and now that i think about it it might
even be a quite of a suicide because you
actually
open the e file and you have your king
on this file so even if the e3 pawn
would be
the your pawn up it's still it's a
backward pawn
there is the e5 e4 e4 square yes so
it's definitely worth sacrificing that's
right i think that this is
scary for white especially in this time
control where black now has
an extra minute and a half on the clock
the king is in the center i see what the
evaluation says but the move like f3
even though it stabilizes the position
the rook is closed down
i feel like black has these really long
term chances as
white's king maybe actually now will go
to the king side now i think about it
wait a second
it's funny i thought the king would
never go in that direction but perhaps
the next move for white if to say this
knight goes back to f6 is just to
try to castle kingside weird position
yeah it definitely seems more more solid
here for the white's king
um how about knight f2 trying to
to insist on opening the position i
think it's a reasonable plan because
even if right now you see it's only
0.5.6 that means that it's one extra
pawn but it's not really a full extra
pawn it's because this king
is still a bit out in the open black can
continue with the initiative here so i
think knight f2 is a very reasonable
choice
if you want to go for the attack and it
seems that knight f6 was played because
not our material dean i say this all the
time it's not my material i'm always
willing to sacrifice it but during a
game i would probably also play
knight f6 just out of a little bit of
concern and then i look at the
evaluation and says nope actually that
move wasn't so great because now white
is plus
over one so it's just a nice position
for white although knight g3 seems
a bit inaccurate still i'm starting to
appreciate white's position more and
more
yeah but you know what it's still kind
of okay it's in the middle of
a rapid and a blitz format so
it's usually good to play a little bit
too active here
trying to oh oh
too active though right oh yes uh i was
like i was listening to you i was like
agreeing with you and then i was like oh
wait i see the evil bar
jump up there must be something and
knight takes d5 just
wins this knight on h5 tactically uh oh
sorry dean i didn't mean to cut you off
will she find it
i think so i feel like this is a tactic
yep she played it she played it big turn
of events here in this matchup
and bishop e6 played what
it's not over yet their knight is pinned
so if i
take yep queen takes and can i just
steal this pawn e3 just say i stole two
of your pawns
are you deal with it bishop c4 is also
possible here
going for some tactics and that's what
she play she's confident right now
she's just taking charge of the position
yeah that's a little bit
too active for black yeah and it's so
easy to miss this knight takes d5
because
that palm was protected by another pawn
and we always say pawn's best friend's
another pawn
but that tactic was available the king
was open you were saying that the king
didn't feel quite that safe
for black and that was a pawn drop and a
big turn of events here
in this match so
we'll see if uh international master
russia
nunja will be able to fight back but
let's keep on going we have so many good
games to look at here's one
grandmaster korboff taking on
grandmaster tuan berg and
this position isn't black up a pawn
where's the compensation
that's a good question
it's like a an extra pawn and
same material except for the pawn i mean
same color bishops
both sides of the knight is white just
trying to claim that
i'm castled i'm more developed so that's
enough perhaps to try to
to bring the f pawn to make it look
scary at least
it seems like you'd have to move the
queen somewhere and then move the
feels a bit slow right yeah it's
definitely too slow
but it seems like it's the only thing
that white could try here
to do yes and wait a second
wait a second
was that i'm almost okay that's a normal
move but at first i saw the move c5 on
move forward without looking through the
moves like wait c5 could that be a mouse
slip
but this is a variation but oftentimes
white you know takes this pawn
rather than goes c5 so corvo is a very
experienced player it seems that tuan
berg just found
a nice tactical sequence in the opening
to win first the e5 pawn and then the c5
pawn so those pawns when they go too far
if you can break the chain
then the pawns start dropping so i think
that black is just happy
you did and
yes so all right 97 played we'll see how
this one continues i want to just
there's just so many games going on i
want to go to dimitri yacovenko against
georg meyer that's a big time matchup
between two superstars and chess
and the last one played with c5 dina
only one piece has been traded
black took on f3 with the bishop that
was a knight there
so what do you make of this position
right now okay the queen on b4
looks a little bit uh misplaced i think
black
should definitely try to put it back
like on a5
in order to escape back to c7 soon
otherwise it
might be uh in trouble there's
definitely nothing more
concrete for now but it looks like it's
not the place where you want to keep
your queen
yeah that queen could be in real danger
there also are tactics right with a gun
knight takes d5 you're not careful here
the knight can recapture but just show
that like
let's say if we yeah if we were trying
to to make it work
a3 like okay now there is the b3 pawn a3
and queen a5
then it would actually work great call
queen a5 walks in the knight takes d5
exposing attack on the queen the queen
takes but then white throws in the
internet so knight takes f6
check once black recaptures white takes
the queen and
that wins a pawn to your right that this
queen is in trouble it might be trapped
but york says no it's not i'm gonna play
e5 i'm gonna break your pawn chain and
the reason why e5 is so strong for black
is a pawn chain this is connect four you
win the game right but the
problem with this is if i can start
breaking down your pawn chain
and you take back with your pawn now the
d4 pawn is a target
that i can try to gang up on so the pawn
chain is very safe when the base pawn is
f2
but a punching is is only as strong as
the base pawn so f2 is strong
d4 is not quite as stable yeah in that
case the queen would become
a force not a weakness but here
i think gerk is being pretty pretty
creative here
putting his screen on b4 i guess a human
being would
wouldn't do that so easily right
oh gosh jakovenko he's up a minute on
the clock it's a big matchup between
gronke
and yondex and rook b1 play what a
curious move and i mean i think some
kind of a3 this is my
idea yeah so and e4 doesn't work right
e4 knight takes e4
the knight protects the queen here we go
finally right
another fancy temporary looks like a
sacrifice but in fact it just steals a
pawn so
uh wow e4 also leaves the pawn chain
intact so that's probably not what black
wants to do regardless
but queen a5 now makes sense because
knight takes d5 hey it's the same tactic
right
guess what your queen's not defended
because that rook went to b1 and that's
what happens at these high level games
these small little moves change the
dynamic
completely and george went e5 and then
saw the
opportunity to drop the queen back maybe
that queen will go to c7 as you
mentioned dina i like black's chances
here
yeah absolutely you could try a sneaky
little b4
hoping that the black would take and
then you would go for bishop a1 and rook
takes b7 but i guess there will be just
queen c7
right so we wouldn't gain much well i
mean still the plan that
it's the plan it's the plan indeed they
drew what
they drew why oh no
oh no this is so frustrating
why did they do that yeah why would they
do that i have very strong opinions
about draw offers and
well for yakivenko i'm guessing at this
point he probably wasn't thrilled with
the position that's pretty closed
but in a team event you look at your
other boards and you have to weigh
hey it's not just about me maybe i want
to win my game but let's see how the
rest of the boards are doing so
i'm going to try to find those boards
actually here alina kashminskaya is
board
2 for gronke and she has the white
pieces well from
derek meyer's perspective that just like
looking at this board white seems to be
in good shape so he said okay i'll make
a draw with black against
uh super grand master and now alina
you're higher rated you have a nice
position because of the
advanced pieces here everything doing a
good job for white but
how do you actually break through how do
you win this game dina
well it's not it's not so easy to be
honest and alina is known to be a very
sharp and tactical player here the
position seems
more solid so that's gonna be pretty
interesting for us to see how she will
try to outplay her opponent
i like to start though bishop f2 is a
sneaky move because like wait what are
you doing
you're gonna play h4 i also could play
knight e3 matty 3 to bring the knight to
f5
and this could be a case of at first
like was this not on d3 doing the pawn
e5 is well protected so maybe
this knight comes to f5 and then this
knight comes to c4 a4 so you kind of
just
switch places with your pieces and then
f5 is so powerful
because the king has to go away maybe
you'll get a knight to the d6 square so
essentially what i'm trying to say is
this knight will come to c4 to replace
the other knight will come to f5 so
it'll look something like this knight d3
would be a dream position
but you know what thinking about the
just the previous result we saw
it made me think uh jakuenko is
definitely a
a world-class grand master but we
shouldn't forget that he hasn't been
active for
for years now and uh i would actually
put on george meyer more than on him
so for me that that draw result was
little bit too early
yeah it uh definitely caught us off
guard and for those of you watching i
can see you in the chat
so i'm we're as surprised as you are and
for those of you who are here please
just quick reminder for everyone that
feed it has an ongoing charity event
type the command donate in chat for more
information how to donate
donations will show up on screen it's
very greatly appreciated for some super
important initiatives including players
with disabilities
veterans of chess and chess and
education so thank you so much for the
continued support
as we continue analyzing these games so
the pawn structure has changed
completely
it looks like elena still has an
advantage but this knight can come to e5
at some point maybe some trades the king
come to e6 we will
come back to this game just because so
much is happening i feel like we can't
stay on any one game for too long we're
following all the top matches from the
various groups we have jan napomnishi's
game
looks like he is just winning at this
point he's also playing somebody
i don't think 1898 is the accurate
rating for the opponent but
clearly on the hot much higher rate of
the two and
know two extra points is my math right
yes uh
absolutely you're right two pawns up for
yan and um
seems to be pretty much winning but okay
it's it's still about converting
yes i'm being told the rating for what
is 25 27 so
1898 not very accurate representation of
the player's
strength and yet jan is that good where
he makes grand masters you know 2500
plus players
and says i'm up two pounds with black
and now i can go and win this game so
this knight on a3
does defend b5 this knight on e5 can
actually go to g4 if you're not careful
hitting the bishop in the pawn
this seems like it will be a
straightforward win for yon maybe
i don't see the way forward i trust yon
to do it
uh for his team so let's uh he will
definitely find a way with this bishop
on g7 being there
like a serial killer on the phone c3
too good that bishop's too good i just
saw another game
this one here between hannah marie
collect this is in grenke
against yandex she is up a bishop
white has these two pawns and i see the
eval bars a huge
advantage for black and i agree with
that because the pawns can't quite
coordinate or this pond would love to
get to a6 not happening yet
but dina i could see a future where
white does not lose this game and these
pawns can be very scary if black's not
careful
yeah once the the second pawn comes to
a6 a6 they will be stronger than the
rook as we all know
and to connect past phones so i guess
there is a lot of contemplate here
right and we just reminded everybody
that we saw a draw on the top board so
it's with even half half to this point
and this would be a really big victory
for gronke if
uh hunter cluck is able to take this one
and
her position looks great she's doing
well here so let's see
if we can keep going and just every
match is important at this stage
and a5 was played there looks like we
have
a game well this is a strange position
where like black's pieces aren't
developed and for and
not being the perfect blockader at all
but here we go rook on t5
in front of the isolated cone
it's uh isolated pawn rook good
bishop pear but that bishop on f8 not
out the rook on h8 caught in the corner
so these uh this game still very unclear
as to the directions i'm pretty much
surprised why this is still um
considered to be an equal position
looking at that bishop and the rook it
makes me
brings me some pain yes and this is
a morgan stanley hungary versus uh
rossetti volga so this is a
very important match of the top of their
group right now
and it's more insanely hungry you see
the hungarian flag for peter
lizac here so g5 i like that move i feel
like it just takes up space
and i guess black isn't in any hurry to
get the
king side pieces out but you can even
consider putting your rook on jade at
some moment if you can get up
these pawns going up the board i guess
it's more about activating the bishop on
the first place and also taking the
space
with the g4 probably getting rid of the
knights
right this knight would have to go back
and then black saying all right i'm
going to keep
making progress here rook c7 clear
attack on this pawn on b7
and this is the pool c top match i think
rook d7 is a great move if you take
the king can just replace the rook and
the bishop hair
that's what's trying to make its mark so
i like black's position in this game
gotta quit keep bopping around if that's
okay with you d not just so many
interesting games catching my attention
including this one here
where happening i can't calculate
quickly enough
this under attack if that king were a
rook i think that
this would be pretty devastating but
that's a king
in the past
so this is uh and this e6 pawn seems to
be uh
so strong but yet uh we don't know yet
how to use it
right so this position looks good and
now the queen can go take on h3 this
king is in the way
so probably slide back to h8 and black
only 53 seconds so we're going to keep
on going here
i'm totally confused here with white
advantage when you see that it's black
who's attacking
i think it's because of this pawn e6 i'm
guessing the long term favors white even
if the short term looks scary
and i see that we were looking at this
game earlier between ryosuke and nanjo
he has the advantage remember he was the
one who blundered this knight takes d5
she's
true on d5 look at this king walking in
here
like this king is going to help win he's
he's making the mating attack
yes this king is helping out this rook
on b7
this is board for for morgan stanley
hungary and rosetta volga so this is in
pool c
the top match this king is entering i
think there's nothing that white could
do how did this turn around we'll
probably check
in the break between rounds five and
round six but what a turnaround dina
this is
not what you want to see if you're from
team rossetti volga
and this is absolutely what you want to
see when you're commentating
right you would like to see the king all
advanced and coming into f3
helping in the attack is the move rook
to e1 but none of white's pieces can
move after that and rook
ooh you can even push e2 oh wait that's
free bishop
i didn't realize the bishop was hanging
that's even better oh
nice oh this is just this is just not
good at all
e2 93 rook f1 checkmate that's the
the plan from here this is
looks pretty over with honestly yeah as
i told you the king will participate in
the attack
and uh there's nothing that white can do
unfortunately first she's stuck
let's uh go on over quickly to this game
out of court my eye here it's an end
game where black is
down a bishop for three pawns or you
could say up three pawns for a bishop
and white is trying to win this this is
an optiver matchup they're not in first
place but they're near the top
they need this victory and each geary
and co trying to
win their group but it looks like white
is the one with the advantage
that's a very interesting uh end game
you
if you want to to fight for the draw
here you just need to
exchange the last a4 pawn
but it seems like white can try to play
for a win i say very skeptically oh whoa
whoa whoa that's a big decision trading
off the dark square bishops
yeah okay white cell has a hope because
the
the a8 square is of the right color
but it seems like there is no way you
could
take the b6 pawn without getting
yourself in trouble with a
queen promoting from the black side oh
oh
e4 check e4 check oh e4 because the
bishop took you at c2
and e4 again oh gosh no time for the
players but e4 cuts that bishop off
you have to there it is yes he made it
he made it that's what i told you
you didn't have any time to go for this
b6 pawn no
you were absolutely correct and now
there's a queen on the board and this is
a win
for international master david parker
simon and queen b1 check okay you can
just
stop this pawn should not be too
difficult for him to figure out and then
this e
pawn will also start moving absolutely
so okay you gotta be careful a7 that's
getting real there's a check check check
check on check
bishop c6 oh then you could even at some
point think about taking it like it's
very no it doesn't work here it doesn't
work but look at this
oh this one is nice sacrificing the
queen for the pawn
and then the new one queens yeah and you
go to the white square and he cannot
stop you
oh gosh is that pawn we're one step up
and here i guess queen a8 would be
would be nice queen a8 would be a
beautiful one
so i think the queen is just going to
snake around somehow
just try to get closer and closer and
actually the queen
and then will be checkmate in two you
will pick in d6 queen b6 and queen
season will be a checkmate
yeah actually kd6 earlier was good game
gg6 now come on and the checkmates
well now if the king of the eight now go
king d6 here qb6
your plan there it is and the
championship
it's always funny when you get in there
wins on time but you give your opponent
a queen and yet you just go deliver a
checkmate like
that's a standard idea and if we go back
in time to when e4 was available for
several moves and
i'll try to see if there any other games
to look at but just at this point here
the bishop needs to stay preventing the
pawn and the great thing about bishops
is they're long range pieces
so they can keep an eye on the diagonal
so king take c3 was necessary
because now e4 king d4 and it's white
who's going to win the game because i'm
going to take this pawn
and then i'm going to stop your your
other pawn and e3 king d3
i just move my bishop a bunch of times
and then i'm going to win your pawn
because your king has to
let go so amazing so there was actually
a way to make it work for white
if well that was if black pushed e4 it
seems at this point e4 is not the right
move it's a king e3 to be so precise
shouldering the enemy king out so that
you can play e4 next is in the game
but now the bishop has to stay on this
side because that way you cover the
g2 square so it's a you know it's
was a close call here and i'm being told
that
uh optiver is third in the pool you know
it's very close to the top so
a win for them on this board that can be
very
instrumental in their comeback as they
try to take their group but
it might be too little too late but
either way there's a big win for them
and a very instructive end game so i'm
just going to
click on the few games to see remaining
this one here
that's morgan stanley hungry and rosetti
volga we were looking earlier
dina we traded the rooks off still even
material still an isolated pawn bishop
pair
how big are blacks 20 chances well from
what i can see the isolated bone the
isolated bone is not
that weakness anymore because there are
no heavy pieces
on the board anymore so that's a good
thing for white
and it's uh it seems to be quite
quite closed even though you know that
it's an open position but i feel
comfortable here with this knight
yeah it's true because also like this
bishop on d5 looks very powerful but
it's not attacking anything and the dark
squares
look at this what are you gonna attack
on this pawn chain so you're like wait
how does black
make progress why is the advantage minus
1.4
almost that seems exaggerated based on
what we're looking at
but how let's talk about how we make
progress first of all do we
take because if we take and we play f5
check
and you go king e5 your king's oh i'm
coming in and i say no you're not
and then my king starts walking up the
board like very isn't it
yeah it's it's it's at least perpetual
here
yeah you can just go back and forth
that's actually really funny so
it's a situation where you push back and
then you're gonna cut the board
yeah i'm actually looking for a meeting
that something like
k7 threatening bishop yeah
maybe but can get out of it but
okay in any case it's it's not that you
don't feel
any win here for black yeah there's no
necessary win on the spot but i feel
like getting the king to d5
would be good so the problem with it is
you give up your bishop for the knight
and he actually goes for it but he's
going to bring his king up and he's
playing this exact line he wants to
blockade the pawn with the king
that pawns on a dark square and i could
see a zook swan in the future dina where
if we just go forward a couple moves
here just to put a position on the board
let's say
bishop that's true with the three there
is this kind of azuki sun but you know
what
they say one weakness is not enough to
win so
if i if i keep my bishop on b2 c3 a1
how would you improve still okay you
attack my d4
pawn i agree it's a big weakness but
where's the second one
i mean it could be f2 or h2 they're
blocked on the dark squares but there is
no way to attack them
but see that's because you have studied
loud chess you're a strong player you
know maybe my bishop needs to change
diagonals whereas i think a lot of
people would keep the bishop here
as it's protecting everything the
problem with this is black is just going
to make these moves
and either you move your bishop and lose
your pawn d4 or you move your king
and then this king starts running into
the position potentially
over here so uh yeah i think that you're
right that white can try to defend in
that manner but it's not going to be a
fun defense
and king c6 played king coming to d5
king c4 this b5 check
check the king off that black king is
very active and i feel like i'm watching
a cappa blanca game and it's he was so
good
at winning positions like this
converting into an end game where
black has the active pieces has the
initiative
but winning this is a different source
so hey your advice is followed
yeah and here's the question i've been
thinking of something like bishop b4
bishop e1 but
there would always be a king e2 so yet
here we go again right how to create the
second weakness
i like that move and at some point you
can play music h4 and f4 but
yeah this would be a nice idea to
exchange on the bones on g3
put your pawn in h3 that feels like a
potentially good strategy
okay and then what's sacrificing then
play bishop d6 at some moment and try to
like
break open four yeah but i would take
that one you see i have enough pawns
there ah
you know i'm trying to make it work and
it's difficult i definitely do not see
at least not immediately yeah and the
advantage is big
for black but it could be a potential
fortress if
white is able to fend this off so at
some point black is going to need to
find a way
to like give the turn to white when
you know azuki's wrong where white has
to move and it's no matter what the move
is it's bad so bishop c1 is played
giving yourself the flexibility
of staring either way i like h4 h3
okay he'll listen to you and now it says
that black is just crushing so
where is the end of this game f4 is
coming i
know not yet not yet
okay at first kind what's next the
question is what's next
ah i got you you got f4 you exchanged
and then you sack on g3
i'm gonna change my plan oh bishop d8
bishop b6 and e5 and then i'm gonna go
for your pawn
oh nice oh wow i think that is the plan
that you need to
execute and there's plenty of time for
black and f4
yeah that move looks pretty good but
maybe you're trading off too much and
then your g4 pawn is potentially
a target later in the game so i think
that bishop d8 you can't stop me from
getting to b6
and then i don't know how you stop me
from playing e5
oh did the engine didn't like that move
he doesn't see it yet
he tries to make something in order to
improve his position
yes and i would play bishop a5 because i
keep talking with bishop d8 bishop b6
maybe i put my bishop on the most active
way to defend the pawn
but then we could have a way to to play
still f4
and sacrifice on g3 like bring the
bishop to d6 play f4 take on g3
twice and your pawn pass to the queen
right
and bishop a5 played oh gosh that f4
ideas are definitely
for choice here and i'm uh informed that
morgan stanley has already won this
match more recently hungry they're up
two and a half half but remember that
board points are the thing to keep an
eye on so
every single point matters if they can
win this game rather than draw that
might even lock up the group for them so
bishop e7 played
here we have bishop c7 protecting the
diagonal bishop c7
would have been the right move but
pretty sure it would have stopped
from all the ideas your idea you you
were saying adina
this is all you because you're going to
sack a bishop here and because this
pawn's on h3
that pawn's going to go promote this is
yeah it's a quick death
but it's very difficult because you know
when you're
defending this position right you're
defending against
the attack on the d4 pawn you're
defending against f4 you're trying to
defend against maybe bishop coming this
way
like all these different options are
there so you have to be
precise like extremely precise for white
just to survive
and you put your bishop on b6 and then
as this bishop came here
f4 you can even take yes as i told you
it's a principle of the second weakness
here we got even the third one but i i
i'm still
sure that if he had played bishop c7
that might have been holdable still
right now on the bishop e7 bishop c7 to
protect the diagonal
i agree no fun but probably just on the
verge of holding here and if you take
the bishop now
black will not take back but g2 exactly
this looks just winning
pawn takes g3 bishop takes g3 and this
is
thematic because of how advanced black's
pawns were that's why black had this big
advantage the whole time
was you had the advanced pawns and even
though it was equal in terms of material
it was not equal in terms of the quality
of the pawns and black is
creating this h3 pawn is also known to
be as a
backup past pwn it's not a real past
pawn but it's soon to be a passport for
an end game and it's
in any position it's useful to bring
your a and h pawns
until the maximum to advance them
because one day in the end game they
they can serve you and that's exactly
why we saw
international master lizak play h5 h4 h3
just push that pawn up the board
and use that to your advantage the
strength and dina we
probably will look at a little more
detail but perhaps you were right that
around here that bishop on c7 oh not
here because the pawn was under attack
yeah bishop d
bishop b6 bishop e7 and here bishop c7
and i don't see the exact way to break
through here
yeah you know what i would do especially
because there's not that much time left
i would like move my bishop around a
bunch of times and just try to see
yeah definitely try to yeah to
to confuse me yeah wow
well um we have the
results in the books for the top boards
let's show everybody what happened here
look at spare going four
zero led by yon napaneshi they won every
single game of their match
it looks like they're going to make it
through group a cronkite bank
thanks to alina kashlinsky we started
looking at her game we liked her
position but she ended up winning that
and then hannah marie clark we saw her
position up a bishop for a
pawn she won as well so gronky bank now
in the lead
in group d and this is what i told you
yeah this uh
media kavanagh definitely should not
have accepted that draw he should have
continued to fight
yes you you were saying that we were
shocked when that happened so
that half point could make all the
difference but remember the first
tiebreak is or
how they get through is on board points
so they still have a chance even though
they lost the match
uh rossetti volga they had a tough round
they lost
three and a half half to this very
powerful team from morgan stanley
hungary
we just watched a win on board two by
peter lisac with the black pieces in
that end game
over there spare bank trade union i i
see some familiar names
spare spare bank trade union sber
there's something powerful
in the name there because the trade
union wins three and a half half led by
ants on corvo we didn't like his
position
when we first tuned in but we lost sight
of that game and
somehow he ended up winning the game
so a big win for them and then
csob the czech bank they lost
to erg there and look at that three and
a half half so even though these were
the top matchups
somehow one-sided affairs and finally
the state bank
of mongolia playing against european
patent office
it looks like and that was a tie two to
two so some of the top players
in mongolia trying to lead their team
at the european patent office the hague
so oh gosh well it's a long name
it's been that's been the round five and
we still have one more round uh to go
in order to to get the the names of the
people who
of the teams who qualify for tomorrow
exactly and you know what's cool about
this dina is that you know of course
everybody knows certain companies the
names of them and
you know we see companies that maybe are
lesser known but still all this
hidden chess talent many treasures out
there and
well this tournament is not just about
the chess
we of course are having a great time
covering the games but this is also to
raise awareness and you know raise money
for these
great causes chess for people with
disabilities vhs veterans support
program
chess in education so please do please
get involved if you can donate there is
a command
in the chat there is a panel to click
that you can go right there
so we appreciate all the support given
for very worthy causes and dina
round five is in the books we have
one final round remaining of the group
stage
will be locked in i think i want to give
more attention to the
mongolian team we haven't really caught
up with their games just so much action
happening at the same time
but i'm very curious i think that would
be a big achievement and a big deal
because mongolians really do love
chess and i i think that they've been in
a force
for a number of years maybe lesser known
to the broader public but
you know as a very serious chess player
yourself we've seen the rise of many
mongolian talents
indeed absolutely and uh as we said
previously
this tournament is the first edition and
we we
hope to see all those new names to the
chess world to be
future legends of chess you for sure
i mean just so many names here that you
never know or there could be somebody
who
um is playing and they take chess
seriously after this or just people who
haven't played for a long time and
they're just getting back into it having
a good time with co-workers and
i think a lot of people love chess they
sometimes have to put it aside
because of other things in their life
but i i really am happy to see
how many players are taking part in this
how many different companies from all
over the globe
all different types of companies so it's
been great and dina
i'm having fun but it is time for a
break we'll be back in about
15 minutes and when we return we'll go
over some of the action and we'll get
ready
for the sixth and final round of the
group stage
[Music]
and we return we are going to analyze
some games from the fifth
round of the fide world corporate chess
championship
dina we've seen many good games in that
last round some even matchups and
sometimes some sports that were pretty
lopsided with a four or nothing
performance for example
from yonda palmici's spare team we also
seen some lessons for our
viewers hopefully that was
pretty instructive certainly we had some
great
positions to look out for and we pulled
some positions for you all so we can
analyze some specific chess moments
and not just talk broadly about the
matches so for example
there was this game here where you know
white's position
is already looking a little bit like a
struggle it's black's turn the position
the bishop on g7
is looking down at the white king the
queen on c7
is also operating well the rook on d6 on
an open file the 94 i think
get the point all of black's pieces are
looking like they're in
prime position and black move the rook
to d5
nice move defending the pawn needed
defense was under attack twice
knight to d2 and we saw some trades here
dina
and this is an interesting moment
because after rook c5
we can see the evaluation bar is so
heavily in black's favor
but in the game bishop takes b7 was
played
and black quickly took back on b7 and
you see the evaluation bar
changed completely so how do we work on
our mindset so instead of
automatically recapturing even in a
blitz game
how do we work on it so that instead of
doing that we find a way to take on c2
we actually need to always check all the
candidates all the
captures checks and attacks
yeah i think that's a start and i think
it's easy though to overlook that this
bishop is helping you out because rook
takes c2
by itself you know that wouldn't be good
enough but it's because this bishop on
g7 is so powerful
and i just think it's easy kind of to
like forget about it for a second
because when somebody captures in front
of your king you're like okay i gotta
i gotta take that back but it was
available rook takes c2
it would also be an in-between move and
those kind of moves are pretty pretty
easy to to miss that's right and in fact
because black missed this if we go
forward in this game
uh white not only survived
but as we continue here white started
getting the initiative with c4
it takes it still looks a bit dangerous
for this white king but it's starting to
look dangerous
for this black king as well you just saw
the engine it was saying
okay black is better now it's back at a
50 50
scenario and the game continued with
white stealing a pawn on the other side
of the board right it's like
wait we're looking at the king on b1 the
king on a7 and then white says okay let
me take that pawn
because f7 is under attack next and look
at this where
white goes queen e3 rook to d1 all of
white's pieces are now
operating in unison so you know these
games turn around so quickly don't they
absolutely they do and this is
this is what makes them even more
exciting to watch
it really look at h4 the c3 pawn is
protected
white said okay i stole your pawn and
look at it go
it kept going pretty far and now the
queen tried to take care of the pawn
but that's neglecting the king safety
and queen came to d3
into d6 with check and you see that eval
bar skyrocket
because pawns are being lost checkmates
are on the radar here and after king c8
you'll notice
the knight takes away the escape square
so landing a check
that wasn't the right way to go
necessarily but finally to e8
and there's nothing you can do except
drop the bishop back
and that's checkmate here we go one
would never believe into that poem but
it made its way through and can you can
you believe that though we go back to
that position
where bishop took on b7 it really seemed
like black
before that point and we have the
evaluation bar but even without the
evaluation bar it looks so
strong for black and white was able to
defend
and then turn that defense into offense
just crazy turn around
absolutely so i have a couple more games
to
pull up here we have the morgan stanley
hungry team
they won their match and is thanks no
small part to petra pap
very strong player this position you
know the bishop on
c5 protected by this queen and f8 it's a
bit awkward
for black and dina it was really quick
how white turned this position from a
pleasant looking one into an attack so
queen c2
direct attack also eyeing the h7 pawn
bishop needs to move
knight g5 hitting h7 hitting the bishop
on e6
g6 only way to stop the checkmate rook
e5 i mean that move is
excellent that's such a difficult move
to play i feel like because of how many
good moves white seems to have but
rookie five that's class
you bring your rook to the center it at
the same time it might attack and also
participate in the
in the center in the other wing it's
definitely a very tricky move and you
from the at first glance you do not
really understand what this rook is
doing there but then when you look
deeper you
you kind of understand the the whole
the whole meaning of this i think one of
the main ideas
is that if black had a free move bishop
d7 is a way to trade rooks a way to try
to take this knight out from c6
because this knight on c6 is taking away
the rook squares for that rook on a8
so black can hardly move so rookie five
is one of these
fantastic moves it's not a sacrifice it
doesn't threaten anything in particular
but it restricts black even more and
rodent here went queen d6 which looks
normal but look at the bar
because petropap had a tactic up her
sleeve knight to e4
give me this dark square and after queen
to f8 well
i don't mind if i do i take here and f5
was played because after bishop takes
knight f6 check that's a check here this
bishop is hanging
there's going to be dark square problems
as well a really nice way
to win this game for petropak so in the
end of the day that was that kind of a
slow move that had a very big idea
behind
that's right and it can be difficult to
play a move like rook e5 but it just
stops all of black's possible ideas and
it wins the game
and we had some other interesting games
just to
look at here i mean this final position
board one between
uh grand master bachullon
but this game while the end is
particularly clear look at the pieces
slicing through if we go back in time
just
around here it's where i wanted to start
this is a normal theoretical position
out of the english
and neither side can complain too much
the bishop on g2
is staring in long diagonal but black
has
pieces and a center that's quite compact
very solid and i wanted to show this
position dina because
i think what white did makes a lot of
sense very natural
and at this point knight to e4 is a
normal move but you can already see the
evaluation bar
going in black's favor so the reason why
is now that there's a pawn on d4
black wants to use the c3 square for
himself
how does that look the knight wants to
replace white's knight here
that's a knight a4 believe it or not
that's the move you have to play
so that your knight can't get kicked
from the defense of the square it's a
very hard move to play because 94 does
look
thematic it looks standard but after
knight e4 f5
knight goes back knight d5 and after
bishop b2
doesn't help because i put my knight in
here and now i have a pass
pawn this pawn a three's under attack so
dana what can you say about
situations where you're making moves in
the center normal looking moves
how do you like determine when to put
the knight on the rim versus
playing in the center like she did yeah
so first of all what's interesting here
is that usually this night as far as i'm
concerned
doesn't go to c3 in the theory of the
english line it goes to d2
so here we go that's why after 94 for
black which is a very typical move in
this situation
the knight on c3 is getting directly
attacked so it took us
three moves if i count correctly to get
to d2 instead of one
this might be a reason for the trouble
for weight
and uh as for your question i guess in
that situation it was already quite
desperate and you needed to come up with
something and not so easy to find the
right approach
when you're already having a slight
let's call it
a practical trouble yes
it seems so strange because it's move 13
nothing has really happened uh yeah we
just have a trade
okay great doesn't look like white's in
any danger and suddenly you make a move
knight e4
we would all rather our piece in the
center and then e4 attacks eight squares
a knight on a4 attacks only four so yeah
let's put our knight in the center we're
told to do that that's how we learn
chess
but it just so happens that here it's
really about defending the c3 square
so the knight in a4 if you trade knights
you're not getting into c3 you don't
have a piece to get there
and after knight d5 well look at the bar
what is your knight doing there
and you know now that i think about it
actually knight takes d4 for white
doesn't seem
to me to be a very wise decision as far
as i remember it might be even 92 here
for whites
just that actually is the theoretical
move i believe
to open up the bishop and to not allow
this pawn to d4 to cause
white some problems so it's still a
theoretical discussion
the player is probably familiar
generally speaking
with the ideas here but yeah knight to
d4 instead
it's amazing how quickly a position can
turn around where it
you know black is the one getting active
you of course don't want to take that
knight
and give up your light square bishop and
get attacked and bishop be too nice
either i think black played an
excellent game to just put a knight in a
one right
that's not a happy piece that's a dream
for black
yeah and i think it was pretty easy you
take this pawn a3
and then we saw the final position but
it was just a very
one-sided game so small mistakes they
can also come in pairs and once that
happens
your position can actually collapse way
more quickly than you would anticipate
and this was from
uh the match with the mongolian team
yeah that was a typical example how you
should not play chess
right and it's funny because just to go
back
one more time and i've been saying it's
funny it's really not that funny for the
player with the white pieces
but 94 these moves don't seem bad
one by one but in conjunction with one
another that's when it
doesn't work so i think that uh somehow
the coordination wasn't there
for white and black was able to take
over and i do have
one more game that i wanted to show
because i thought this one was very
interesting from
spares board three international master
lavrov
this is a very complicated position
where there's a pawn on d6
that's a past pawn supported by a queen
in a rook
and yet you'll see that the evaluation
bar says black is better
but if you make one inaccuracy that
position might even lose the advantage
you could actually be close to losing if
this pawn gets to d7
and say the knight gets to c4 or i can
continue to stack my piece on the d
file it just seems like black could be
in big trouble
and that's why international master
lavrov went
c4 a really excellent move opening
the queen up to the pawn f2 trying to
say please move your b-pawn and get
checkmate and so i think
part of this dina is like a not
desperate but you're clinging on to
attacking hope so you don't just get
rolled over but this move c4 that's good
awareness by black
well it's opposite co opposite castles
and
uh the the most important rule about
playing the opposite
castle's position is to be faster than
your opponent it's it's about the race
and
whoever attacks first he gets he gets it
all
right and while the king on g8 is
actually pretty safe for now it's the
pawn and d6 that's such a problem
and the game continued here just a
couple moves d7
rook d8 and rook d2 trying to defend
this pawn
on f2 and if queen takes c4
several ideas come to mind for black one
of which is rook a5 if i want to bring
my rook
in to the fifth rank also just queen
takes f2
hitting the knight threatening checkmate
over here
and black already is the first the
attack
so queen c3 would be a way to defend
both ideas at the same time but
i drew the arrow by accident i was
trying to draw to b2 a2 not defended
and rook a6 rook c6 looks like a big
problem for
this king on c1 so it's like a very
tricky position
black is the first one to attack but
this pawn on d7
is still something that white can take
pride in and in the game
after rook d2 was played c takes b3 now
the
king was open and you lost your pride
and joy that past pawn so once that pawn
drops
i think the advantage is very clear for
black absolutely
so those were just some games we wanted
to go over from the various groups
we know the standings we can see that in
the final round we'll know which
matchups are important spare
wins the group with just a draw they
have 18 and a half points
next has 14 naps so a single draw will
win them
the group i that's pretty clear in group
b though gronkey did beat yondex but
that's only a one point spread so if
there is an upset where gronkey loses
yandex
or arista group or one of the others can
come back but what do you think is
gronky gonna take the group
uh they they better try at least
yeah but what's your mentality you've
played team events before you're
up so you you take it cautiously you say
all right maybe we only need to
you know get two and a half points or
two points so you just play like it's
the first round and just
you know not focus on the overall
standings well playing a team
event is very particular and it is way
more fun when you think about it because
you you don't have
like from one side it's okay you you
have a pressure you have a lot of
pressure because uh you like
your result depends on the team result
but from the other hand
your result doesn't matter that much
because there are three more players
that
they are fighting for the same reason
and one more thing about the teamwork
end is that
you can you can actually make draw and
nothing will happen
the most important thing in when playing
the team events is
to um is not to lose
so i guess i guess it's all about the
team spirit here
and uh whoever has the higher one
he gets the he gets the points yeah
and it just can be tough mentally where
you think oh let's just play it safe and
sometimes play it safe is actually
more risky than uh you know playing your
typical style so
it looks like grunke they're in good
shape but they need to
prove it in this final round morgan
stanley hungary is a point and a half
ahead of
gazprom and two points ahead of optivar
so
the anish giri led team is doing very
well they're performing
admirably there they actually have more
match points than the team in second
place
but board points is what determines the
standing so gas problem is
a head of team optivare and this final
match will be
deciding that that group and group d
spare bank we saw
sparring group a in group d i think we
recognize
the name spearing trade union led by
anton korbov
they're in first but this paypal
bulgaria team dina led by sergey
airenberg
and antoinette stefanova very strong
team with two grandmasters on the boards
there so they have a chance to upset the
team
but they need to win if they play spare
rank three to one that's
that's going to be a tough one to do and
that's the kind of a match that we want
to see
in the last decisive match of the day
yeah right you you at least if you could
play the team in front of you
you have that chance right you want to
play that team rather than have them
play someone else you control your own
destiny and in pool
group e you see that erg is ahead
um the czech bank in second place there
but they
just played one another so will they be
will check bank be able to catch up will
uh gord it there in
third place be able to knock out erg and
overtake them
some it's going to be difficult one half
points is a lot but
sometimes a round goes really wrong we
saw some three and a half half
four zero performances in the previous
round these things can happen and
finally
in pool f we see that the state bank of
mongolia in first place but only one
point ahead of empty solutions so that
one is really close there are two other
teams that czech national bank
and uh rfso locomotive that's
you mentioned european clubs isn't that
a popular
russian club well
surprisingly um i don't see uh
i don't see those names here but i guess
what's good about it that we already
said perhaps is that uh
this first corporative championship can
bring us a lot of new names
as teams and clubs for the future
right i i just maybe i'm mistaken but i
thought locomotive is uh
some in the russian league yeah
definitely in the football
yes okay so maybe i was thinking
football and then i mixed up with chess
yeah yeah yeah football and absolutely
because i do enjoy uh football for sure
so that's probably where the mix-up is
happening that's a very very big team
unfortunately not here in in chess but
that's what i was
telling you about we shall see soon yeah
no that would be
fantastic and as we have been saying
these companies often
sponsor and are involved with many
different
leagues sports different charities as
well
and this event is raising money for
the following initiatives chess for
people with disabilities the
feed hs veteran support program and
chess in education all
very worthy causes so if you can please
do
check out the panel on twitch
you can use the command donate to get
involved to show your support
it really means a lot to the broadcast
community to so many people around the
world so we're appreciative of that
we are going to take our final break
before the final round so stay tuned
everybody you will not want to miss
round six to determine which teams will
move on to tomorrow's playoff
[Music]
and here are the pairings for the final
round of the group stage of defeated
online world corporate chess
championship
you see that yonda palmachi taking on
elvira behrend a very strong player
this matchup between european investment
bank and spare
that's going to decide who wins group a
group b has gronka bank and airster
group
and i'm curious dina about your opinion
in group c
because optivar comes out of nowhere and
nieth geary leads the charge they
need to beat morgan stanley because they
are currently two points behind
so if they win three to one they'll
leave their top three boards because on
board four they're very outraged
do you think they have a chance to win
on boards one two and three
and try to take this group from morgan
stanley
i think even if the chance is small they
definitely have to
have to to give it a try and yeah as far
as for me it's
it's hard to to root for someone
against anish so i would really hope for
them to win
it's gonna be a really intense matchup
there we have
uh emco taking on spareway trade union
we know anton korbov leads the charge
for them
erg against gordic erg in first place by
one and a half board points and finally
we have the state bank of mongolia
leading group
f and they are one point ahead of the
second place team uh rfso locomotive is
in third one half points back
but it is an open group no group has
been decided
mainly the spare team led by yana pomshi
i think there are four points so they
will probably win their group but let's
go to the games
because they're underway and we
start talking about niche geary we might
as well look at the game against lavon
bergadzi a strong international master
look at the center though right here for
white i know this is
an opening that block can go for but
would this be your choice
against niche gary definitely not
i would i would for sure go for some
someone that could at least
promise you to equalize yes
uh this is just handing the center a6
okay i get it trying to play for b5 at
some point
but white is just developing taking over
the center this is like a dream come
true
for a niche and while we do dive more
deeply into the games i just want to
thank everybody who has donated see that
donation bar there
the number is going up over 6 000
raised thus far it's greatly appreciated
for these initiatives and
i see we pulled a niche gary on screen
you know dina he's probably
playing his game but also has the tabs
open for his teammates rooting them on
hoping that the team from optivar can
make that final
push and win the group
definitely he's the one who inspires the
whole team
and uh he just does what he has to do
yes and well developing is what he has
to do black at some point needs to
strike
either with b5 or an e5 type of move if
you can make that work
because you're lacking space and you see
the eva bar plus
one pretty much for white and each plays
the column of a3
try not to open the position bragazzi is
an aggressive type of player
so if you can keep the position closed
look at the center
all four minor pieces develop black is
only two
minor pieces developed the queen side
pawn structure is compromised
perhaps dina will see something with d5
but i think anish is ready for this
yeah definitely black needs to try to
bring at least one phone to the center
and we
are witnessing this right now okay and
bishop d3 back take me on e4 i'll get an
isolated queen pawn but then you will be
left with isolated
queen side pawns and those are two hard
to keep track of so a niche in a good
position i'm gonna keep on going because
we do have so many games to look at
uh this is the matchup between gronke
with alina kashlinskaya
on board two playing with the black
pieces
standard king's indian i don't think we
need to stay here
for very long it's very early going
we'll try to come back
at a good moment but so far locked up
position
black at some point we'll try to strike
with f5 and white can even play a move
like g4
to stop f5 from happening so let's keep
on
going i don't even know where should we
should stop because there are too many
good options at this point
i'm looking at ants on korvov's game
because at the corner of my eye i saw
king on the eight i saw pawn five
dina whose attack is going to be
stronger
oh well um again um
opposite castles well black king isn't
yet castle but still
so to be opposite castles it's all about
the race
whoever is faster wins the game here
i can see that white has not only
started
opening the the the position of the king
but also is taking the lead in the
center
and whoa corbett made that move and the
look at that the evo bar
is jumping up for white so there must be
a tactic here
and i wonder oh i think i know what it
is knight
d to b5 hitting this queen
with the bishop it feels like there's
something there if knight
to b d to b5 see a queen b7 to try to
keep the
uh pin alive maybe there's even queen
takes d6 trying to deliver a checkmate
and if bishop takes knight takes d6 is a
check
that's a fork at the very least white
stole one pawn but i think it's going to
be much worse than that
definitely the only thing is that they
will
exchange the queens and so to be white
will not be able to attack anymore is
that worth
it i would i think i would taking that
material against corbin
b3 and i really don't like b3 because
it's not tactical and you're opening up
your king you may think all right i'm
putting a pawn in the queen's path
that's a good thing and of course it is
to prevent the mate but i think that you
could have just quickly ripped open the
position
and we saw the evaluation bar was
justifying this knight to b5 move
we also know the players don't have that
luxury they can't just say oh it's
plus three if i make this move they're
trying to figure it out on their own and
knight d to b5 while it was available
maybe it's a bit tricky
and was miscalculated
so and we shall see we shall paul takes
back white king is feeling safer the
black king may not
find true shelter if bishop e7 you can
push your pawn to f6
keep gripping the position open white
has a spatial advantage
white has a lead on development and the
lead on the clock so right now
and this matchup between uh emco and
spare bank trade union it looks like
korabov
needs to figure it out how to get at the
opening and i'm just gonna
really just bop around so bear with me
dina and chad i know
it's gonna be hectic pull up the game
between david
simon and petra pop we know that optivar
against
morgan stanley hungary we're still in
the anish giri matchup if you will
and what do you make of this dino where
optivar white pieces in this match they
need some wins here
do you think they're playing something
slow and methodical that we see with uh
this position or should you try to get
aggressive
i actually think that wherever it it's
going to be next
uh what is why is having a very decent
position
it might be equal on the evaluation bar
but i think that it's
it's that kind of position with that
gives a really
a really slow but little but stable
advantage for white and this is this
might be
this might be pretty interesting for
them here trying to improve their pieces
little by little
you know as as i enjoyed the chance to
be rook on d1
pawn on a4 it looks promising for white
here to me and
petropab very strong player she's saying
all right maybe
i don't have the clearest plan myself
but neither does white and this bishop
on h7
it's kind of a devilishly strong piece
because it hits the pawn e4
and that pawn goes up to e5 and the c2
pawn could become a quick target so i
think that
black's position is actually quite
stable and it's hard for white to find a
plan
but then again white is up quite a bit
of time at this stage and that's what
you want to do is
play on the board but also press your
opponent on the clock
and you also do not want actually to
play e5 because it would
it would ruin your b2 bishop oh here we
go
e5 e5 from black but that frees up some
of these light squares i'm already
thinking can i go knight h4 and knight
f5
uh at some point can i play maybe now
knight c knight c3 knight d4
93 95. looking at all the squares here i
feel like white gets
new flexibility thanks this e5 move not
that it's a blunder it's not at all
but i move like knight c4 already puts
pressure on that pawn so you give up e4
to win e5
and that's the very least a fair trade
and white's pieces start to
open up so let's uh keep our
rotation we're going all around here to
see different games different matches
i'm gonna put the magnus carlsen game
because while his team from kindred is
not at the top of the standings
i saw the rating differential and you
get a chance to play magnus carlsen
that's really exciting of course
i don't imagine that the player with the
black pieces is rated 259 that's just
their online
rating here on chess.com and rapid chess
but it's a mismatch on paper it's a
great opportunity to face off against
the world champion
so it's uh once in a lifetime yes that
kind of movements that you
really want to enjoy right and well
the position for black is actually okay
for now
where you have a solid positioning of
your minor pieces all
in the center the problem though is
especially when you take on d5
white's plan for an attack is very clear
because
white did not does not have pieces on
the queen side there's nothing to attack
like b4
doesn't attack a knight so it doesn't
gain a tempo a5 may just drop the b5
pawn but even if you start pushing your
pawns up
at a certain point you have to actually
threaten something and white's plans of
h5
and g6 and f4 it just feels much more
natural
absolutely looks devastating here
yes so it looks
very very good here for white magnus
playing
uh his final match here the team will
not move on but kindred
picked up a pretty good player in magnus
carlsen i think we can say
he's done all right for the team
yeah there is no doubt for that yes
so 1858 is the
player's rating for black so 259
misleading but magnus still has over a
thousand points
or approximately a thousand points on
the opponent that's pretty wild to think
about
so we're going to leave magnus for now
well we'll say goodbye to him in this
tournament we will see him very shortly
in many other
tournaments but it's great that he's
participating in the
fide corporate world chess championship
so let's move
i'm gonna go back to niche gary's game
if you don't mind dina because that one
looks
spicy and white is down in exchange
but that king on h8 in the corner that
could be an attack
the engine says white is doing well what
do you think when you look at this
position
how do we deliver a checkmate usually
first thing you
you want to analyze is some sacrifices
or the ways how to get the king
and that's not so easy you don't see the
any easy way there because
thanks to the doubled e7 pawn the f6
square is protected the e5 pawn is uh
so to be blocking your own bishop so the
diagonal
looks weak but stable at the same time
you don't see the the clear path here
perhaps something like h4
h5 could be an idea bringing the rook
some somehow to d3 to f3 g3
h3 but yeah there is definitely an
advantage here the question is so
how to proceed in the concrete way yeah
that move
rook d3 in the future looks very good
and h4 is multi-purpose you threaten h5
and make sure you don't get back
checkmated so i think that h4 is
by far the best move and when you try to
defend against an attack sometimes you
just have to
say i'm going to put all my pieces in
front of your attack other times you
bring them like rook c8
and try to take over the other side of
the board and create problems so rook d3
was played by anish
no background checkmate just yet but if
that queen landed e1 that would be
a checkmate of course anish will see
that he's not going to get checkmated
i think that his position is great he
has h4 and as you said dina
the rook can go from f3 or g3 or h3
white has tons of options at his
disposal
so i i think he's going to win this game
i i feel pretty confident his chances
here
now unless he blunders something
definitely he is going to run this
agreed and i'm going to pull up the game
of george meyer we're going to switch
matches to the gronkin match
because i see at the corner of my eye
the last one played a6 and it's
ursta group trying to take down gronke
and a6 it's such a nice move because a
pawn chain i say this very regularly
a pawn chain is only as strong as its
base pawn there is no pawn chain anymore
because the palm it's a6
now you can just steal the c6 pawn but i
must say
despite the fact that white is up a pawn
black has some very good compensation as
this bishop on c1
yeah look at that bishop it's so
ridiculous okay
now there is a hope with the b pawn
moving but
until it moves anywhere it looks so
ridiculous it's like
wasting his time in the bathroom
god knows what yeah and i think that
york should try to consider like rook c3
and the plan that i'm wanting to go for
is a rook c3 if you take me then i can
take back and my bishop is free i'll
take
the d-pawn not to give you a pass pawn
and now if i trade
maybe i can move my rook get like or
just try to get my king around somehow
and push my d pawn
if your rook moves so it's a slow
approach but i think york
can go for it he is a i mean he's a
grand master of chess but he has
masterful technique
in these types of positions he thrives
in them i played him so many times
in blitz chess and he just grinds his
opponents down
from the slight advantages and he knows
how to nurse that advantage to a full
point
yeah it's going to be a tough game for
laura but um
we shall see yes we shall
let's uh go to board two in this matchup
elena kashlinskaya with the black pieces
it's locked up on the king side which is
good news
for black because that means that white
isn't going to go check my u
and on the other hand black at some
moment can play f6 or f5 to break open
the king side so the side that controls
the
uh the tension the pawn breaks
usually the side that has the advantage
so i actually like alina's position
do you agree tina yeah there is a lot of
future in this position there are palm
breaks there's the very nice knight on
c5
i guess the the white skin white skin
doesn't feel himself that comfortable
okay for now there is no attack but
where would you put it if you go to
g8 then i'm definitely trying to rip
open the position at some point with f6
or f5
and i like king h7 just to protect g6 in
case and i like knight b5
because if black is not careful knight
takes d6 will happen so i imagine
b6 is the response here for black
and look at this a4 pawn how how far
it's gone and how many
how many space has it already achieved
there
it looks great yeah it's just taking
over space the rook or the queen can go
to a5 at some point
to use that square and the space so i
like it
for now though of course the d6 pawn and
the c5 knight oops sorry
are under attack so need to be uh
watching out for that so by the way
magnus carlsen did win that final game
and
oh gosh i'm gonna pull the position up
checkmate with a pawn
oh wow that's been fast this was pretty
fast
even though the position looked like the
only one way
to go but still i wonder i wonder what
the line was what the uh
odds were for a check meeting with a
pawn because uh univet
now kindred they uh do sports betting
and fantasy sports and all that good
stuff so
it would be funny to know what the odds
were on that so
checkmate there let's uh keep on going
to
this position here is a board three for
gronke
against aristotle group and we see that
the bishop on d3 hitting the pawn on h7
the bishop one of four hitting the 96
but i'm also looking at this pawn c4
dina it feels like
this pawn structure could be quite
questionable for white
it doesn't look good definitely not for
for white it it's a total weakness and
look at this look on c1 in front of
three pawns looks totally ridiculous
what is she even doing there
although this g6 move changed the
evaluation i'm guessing
that i would put my rook on e1 with
check the king has to make a choice if
your king d7 i just can win a pawn
directly
by bringing your king up to go rookie
six and even without rookie six
now the pawn c4 is safe and you can play
a4 if you need to maybe a5 to crack the
queen set open
or h4 h5 to crack the king side open and
this pawn situation center is very good
for white and
of course the rook can come to e6 which
is the first thing i mentioned
that's that's a very nice position from
the strategy i think we can learn a lot
from this one
yeah i think rookie one to start with
and then i
i you might have to take this 96 because
now the pawn c4 is under attack so i do
think that white has a strategic
advantage king f7 does not fall victim
to these rookie six tactics
that's a smart move but you take on d6
play a4 you get a bind
with your pawns and your pieces so
taking the knight off the board
is a good choice also the knight is
known to be the best locator so getting
it off the board could be an interesting
idea for white indeed
yes the knight blockading piece because
it sees over the other pieces if
it's a you know a piece blocking it's
not knight it doesn't see over the rest
of the position in particular against
this pawn on d5 so
looks pretty good now for white at first
i like black's position now i'm changing
my mind
and i'm going to pick up a niche gears
game
oh look at this it's about to end we
have oh exactly what we predicted the
rook
came to the party and now it's
unstoppable
and queen h5 does not stop the checkmate
because queen takes and the rook h7
is mean anyway so let's see the
conclusion queen five played he takes
we're about to see a victory
for board one vodka or we see it anish
geary on screen
he barely reacts i think he's just going
to check his teammates because he won
his game
we need you know for optiver he's
thinking we need
the teammates to go and i'm going to try
to find those games
um let's see i know we were looking at
david pardo
simon before we'll check in here looks
like a very
complicated tense end game where white
has more time
so it looks good for white from the
practical point of view but from a
positional point of view black should be
okay
yeah black seems to be pretty seems to
to have pretty decent position here with
the
pawn on d4 it looks super strong and the
knight on c5 the backward pawn on c2
which is about to get exchanged okay
and take it's taken and you can just
take back so
it looks like you're liquidating
simplifying the position that's probably
a good thing
uh for petra pop and optiver needs
white to win this game they absolutely
must have a victory on this board
otherwise they can't come back and make
it to the playoff tomorrow
yes that that's the plan for black and
uh wha what's the what's the next board
showing us um look trying to look
just to see it could be that the games
are done i am trying my best there's so
many games
happening at the same time so many
different teams so i'm doing
this oh here we go here we go i found it
peter liza oh that's bad news for
optivard the last move i just saw
was look at this e6
and what is happening to this king
total breakthrough oh gosh and after f
takes e6
white does have less than a minute but
it's plus 12 here
which means that there must be a win in
the next few moves
oh gosh do i take on g7 to play queen e4
check
first there's also queen e6 queen sixth
of rookie seven to follow that looks
crushing
i'm trying to think how white can even
mess this up at this point because it
looks overwhelming and
the morgan stanley well you better not
ask yourself this question because uh
from from from everything that we saw
we can say that absolutely anything is
possible that's true although
this pawn on g7 bishop supporting it
king on h7
this looks pretty bad for
for black it should be something
checkmating
in the very near future and also white's
not down
any material normally to get a position
like this you have to sacrifice a piece
and it's actually even material so this
is really bad news for
october and i i think this one is going
to conclude soon
in the favor of morgan stanley hungary
who
they played a great team tournament thus
far strong players from
board one through board four and they've
led the group
from the start i'm going to
quickly turn attention elsewhere let's
go here um i don't know which matchup
this is from
so i'm just trying to look like a losing
rook end game here for
white totally losing there's three pawns
up and we have two connected past pawns
e6 and b5 the f5 pawn is about to fall
pretty soon yeah this looks like um a
winning line for
totally winning situation for for black
yes and completely winning for black
it's three extra pawns it is board three
and spare versus europe investment bank
so this is a serious board for my
apologies
in that match up so this is a top board
match ooh and you see the evaluation bar
dipped that means king g4
wait a second maybe we spoke too soon
this
pawn on g5 and it looks like um the
player with the black piece is
misleading
not 1823 2400 plus wait a sec if i take
no way your
cup says you cannot right because the
rook g4 check to show that very quickly
nice trick there g4
and then the king would take here and
the pawn would promote so king h5 played
and now there are some problems this
pawn is under attack to defend it
and this king is coming in i think black
has botched this
no way it's still
two pawns up in the worst case it must
be winning
for for black i do believe so i think
white might win this game
oh no no way ah take on f6
oh my okay this first and then take on
f6 next
white might win this game despite you no
wait three pawns off you
you you're cats okay check on b7 you can
check on e2
rook b6 is actually tempting to win the
a61 first but there is the king e5
but then rookie six oh my gosh your
rookie six check
black was up three pawns and losing
every single pawn
oh no this is so painful
oh my gosh this is unfortunate because
now you take the f6 pawn
every single pawn is lost oh my
oh this is a total drama and white wins
and white wins white 2241 black's right
2018 so black was the higher rated
player
and up three pawns when we tuned in and
it's this move b4
pushing your past pawn we we're always
told that push the pawn
but the king walked forward and was able
to just
win this pawn here and now the black
king is in trouble
after f6 the rook is very active for
white
and how quickly the tables turned here
not just holding
but taking every single last pawn and
black just resigned because king e5
check king d5 king takes f6 the rook
moves away
we have cut the king off and our pass
pawn runs
you know what it's an end game and one
should never neglect the importance of
the king in the endgame and hear what we
see
in this game the importance of the king
in the end game and it costed
black a point and i actually realized
that i
looked at the ratings in reverse it's 20
43 not 2400 so i just reverse it my
apologies everyone
blockchaining is in the 2000 range and
what was the higher rate of player so
let's move on
to the game between optivar oh my gosh
optiver's getting that game here but
they lost on
board two yes they did lose on board too
so it's too little
too late but the time advantage now has
turned into a material advantage
for david parker simon so this is going
to be
morgan stanley hungry they are going to
win this group it seems yeah this
knight end game seems to be totally
winning the ninth end games are known to
be
the same oh my ah
knight takes e4 there's no way to stop
it
oh my gosh that move knight f4 which
looks so reasonable
you can try the jack but there is the
king to d
four or king to e3 whoa trying to move
the pawns because knight c3d forward
went back
and the knight sacrificed those pawns
you were saying
don't feel quick enough you just chase
them down king e4
just about to say how winning it was to
play the night end games because they
were exactly the same as the opponent
games
and here we go white blunder the
sacrifice of the knight against the
pawns and had to
to give back the nightmare to try
something
and here we go king e5 for example
if f6 the king comes back to e6
otherwise
six it's getting pretty close right it
looks like yeah it's it's a little bit
dangerous
okay one second oh there's a check
there's a check you gotta move
you gotta move forward two seconds candy
seven good move if the f7 pawn pushes
you take this pawn and knee seven
there's 98 check
oh drew because white lost on time and
black has no mating material
oh that's amazing oh my gosh and the
king was that's amazing
in knight f7 so it was a droid
was it in the in the real game it would
have never
been counted as a draw uh no that's
special.com rules yes because there's
mating material so actually i wonder
you know if this is under the auspicious
defeat if this actually could be ruled a
victory but either way i don't think it
impacts
the group because uh more assembly
hungary was already
on top so i'm just going to see if we
have any games remaining what the
situation is like
it looks like we have our score board no
we okay the results are not quite in yet
um so let's just take a look i'm trying
to see where to go to from here
and all right so
it's a whirlwind there's so many matches
happening at the same time
and wow just wow that game there at the
end
is still just losing on time in that
position
and my gosh i need to take a breath
because some of those games that game
with the rook end game
up three pawns to lose all four of those
pawns it's just such a sad turn of
events and it happens in speed chess
right dino we've had positions where
you're completely winning i mean even
maria music not to
pick on she blunted a clear rook earlier
today and then she missed the challenge
checkmating too right so it's how
quickly we forget certain things but
uh just a wild turn of events everybody
we are going to uh take a quick break
but before we do i want to remind
everybody that this is an event raising
awareness
raising funds for great initiatives for
charities so please
if you can you see that donation bar on
screen the panel beneath you it's for
chess people for with disabilities chess
veterans and chess in education so do
get involved if you can
and the schedule we will update all the
results
remind you of those but there will be
more chess
in the western pool 5 30 p.m pacific
time
do yourself a favor look at the time
translate it to your time zone
so you can come and watch i will be
having the call for that as well that
isn't
5 30 p.m pacific time that's 8 30
eastern and the results are being
updated there's
so many people working behind the scenes
i would be remiss not to thank everybody
i i know uh there's a lot going on we're
running from game to game match to match
but that's you know the format here
there's six different groups all
happening the same time to put together
an event of this magnitude with all of
these groups the
cooperation of fidei and chess.com all
the arbiters who are spending their
weekend
working with the teams ensuring fair
play you know from an
organizational standpoint this is a
massive success even with
how tricky it can be absolutely and it
came reminding you to us
it's the very first edition of the
cooperative
world chess championship and this is a
very important achievement for v-day
itself because it brings
way more sponsors to our sport and who
knows maybe one day will be
as competitive as as tennis or football
yeah and i do hope that everyone had fun
uh most of all because
you know this is an event for fun
although we do have the updated
results for those top boards so it's fun
but we should have to talk about the
competitive aspects
you see here spare they just can't be
stopped they want 4-0
for the second round in a row they win
their group in group a
we see gronke does defeat airs the group
and that means that they will move on in
group b
optivar goes down but with the fight and
looks like petriff
wins so that win on time chess.com may
roulette is draw
but fidei rules it a victory so petra
absolutely wins that game
it doesn't impact anything morgan
stanley was going to win the group
regardless
in group d over there spare bank trade
union
spearheaded by anton corbeau we saw
initially
it looked like a tactic available for
his opponent and yet he goes on to win
that game and spare bank wins the group
uh spirit trained union i should say uh
erg they stay atop
their standings it seems by beating
gordick
and finally rfs locomotive they do
defeat state bank of mongolia i'm not
sure if it's enough
to overtake them because state banker
mongolia was ahead before the
final round took place
just just wow so
i mean just so much to take in so many
different
uh teams taking part i am very
appreciative of the opportunity to cover
this with you dina i had a lot of fun
today
i know it was a whirlwind i know we were
bopping around a lot but i really
do i need to thank you for being such a
great co-commentator
so did i thank you so much robert that's
been a totally exciting
three rounds that we witnessed today
around four five and six
tomorrow we shall see the playoffs i bet
that's gonna be even more exciting
it's gonna be extremely exciting it's
also going to be easier to follow
because we only have eight teams
rather than as many as we did we thank
everybody for their patience
for their viewership it means a lot to
both me
and us dina and you know everybody who's
put this tournament together
but just the chess community we're
really grateful to have the viewership
and support
and for those of you who have been
donating that is really generous of you
and it goes without saying that uh it's
you're making a difference
and for you know chess for people with
disabilities for the veteran
support and for chess and education it
means the world so thank you to
everybody thanks to the companies who
are taking part
and for the companies who are still
involved the winners of each group i
will see them tomorrow but also
be back for the groups later tonight the
tournament
goes on and the show continues thank you
everybody
we'll be back later for more from the
fide
corporate world chess championship
[Music]
you